MonkaW!
Corona hat jedes Jahr neue Zuschauerrekorde vermeldet und es war in Köln eh schon immer viel zu knapp.
Also der Platz, das war so eng und so nervig.
Deswegen bin ich auch schon ein paar Jahre nicht hingefahren, habe überhaupt keinen Bock mehr.
Eine Presseauswahl, das bringt ja nichts. Du musst dich ja am Anfang akkreditieren, das musst du im Vorfeld machen.
Dann kannst du dann da hingehen.
Der Trick ist eh, dass man nicht den Haupteingang benutzt, sondern rechts um die Ecke läuft vom Bahnhof.
Und dann kannst du da dein Bändchen abholen.
Zumindest war das früher so. Ich war jetzt ja schon ein paar Jahre nicht mehr da.
Weißt du noch, wo ich das erste Mal hin bin?
Also als ich auch schon den YouTube-Channel hatte und ein bisschen was über Games berichten wollte von der Gamescom.
Damals haben die noch gesagt, YouTube-Channel zählt nicht als Akkreditierung.
Du musst für irgendeine Zeitschrift arbeiten und so weiter.
Aber es ging dann doch, witzigerweise.
Das war noch, das ist aber schon wirklich lange her.
Das muss wahrscheinlich 2011 oder 2012 gewesen sein.
Ich glaube mittlerweile haben die keine Probleme mehr, dass du dich mit einem ordentlichen YouTube-Channel akkreditieren kannst für die Gamescom.
Ransomware-Angriff, alle Daten bei Cloud Nordic futsch.
Wer hat Cloud, was läuft da?
Was ist bei Cloud Nordic?
Der Cloud-Dienstleister Cloud Nordic aus Dänemark wurde am Freitagmorgen Häckermäns.
Eines Ransomware-Angriffes, sag ich mal in Lautstärke okay.
Ich denke schon.
Ich meine, es ist ja Windows, da weiß man das ja nie.
Ja, alles gut.
Der Cloud-Dienstleister Cloud Nordic aus Dänemark wurde am Freitagmorgen vergangener Woche Opfer eines Ransomware-Angriffs.
Das ist das Thema bei einer Überprüfung und externen Angriffen, dass sich keine Daten retten lassen.
Ja gut, die können ja froh sein, dass nicht alles abgezogen wurde.
Dass nur Sachen verschlüsselt bzw. gelöscht wurden.
Die sollen froh sein, dass die nicht irgendwelche Daten abgezogen haben.
Jetzt ist die Webseite komplett down.
Ach nee.
Oh, alles klar.
Tja, Cloud halt.
Die bekleckern sich doch alle nicht mit Ruhm.
Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch an vor ein, zwei Wochen das Master-Talken für die Microsoft Cloud.
Da hat Microsoft auch nie irgendwas groß.
Das haben die einfach totgeschwiegen.
Hintergründe zum Angriff, okay, das ist immer ganz spannend.
Cloud Nordic erklärte, dass bei einem Umzug von Servern von einem Rechenzentrum in ein anderes die Maschinen an das interne Netz angeschlossen wurden.
Die Maschinen waren zuvor in getrennten Netzen aktiv.
Auf einigen Servern lauerten trotz Firewalls und Virenscanner unerkannte Infektionen.
Ah, das ist doof gelaufen.
Mit Linux-Server wäre ihnen das wahrscheinlich nicht passiert.
Ich meine, kann dir selbstverständlich im Linux-Server theoretisch auch passieren.
Aber praktisch, also ehrlich gesagt, ich, also, wie nennt man das?
Das wird ja so eine Trust-Me-Bro-Argumentation, ja?
Aber gibt's da so ein spezielles Wort für?
Aber ich sag's euch jetzt trotzdem.
Also, ich bin jetzt seit 15 Jahren professionell in der IT tätig.
Erst bei einem Internet-Provider, dann bei einer Bank, jetzt bei einer Versicherung.
Ich bin früher regelmäßig, Turnschuh-mäßig ins Rechenzentrum geflitzt und so.
Und ich habe bisher nicht einen Linux-Server erlebt, der sich den Virus eingefangen hat.
Aber durchaus schon sehr viele Windows-Clients und Windows-Server.
Mein Windows-Client, obviously, da habe ich euch ja mal erzählt,
da hatten wir richtige Probleme, auch mit Verschlüsselungssachen.
Aber der eigentliche Angriff damals bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber kam ja über nicht gesicherte Windows-Server.
Nicht, letztendlich gemerkt hat man es auf den Windows-Clients,
aber eingefallen sind die über einen ungesicherten Windows-Server.
Ja, Windows halt.
Unsere Linux-Systeme waren die einzigen Sachen, die nicht betroffen waren und mein Linux-Notebook auch nicht.
Das heißt, wir waren die Einzigen, die dort ordentlich arbeiten konnten in der Zeit.
Und helfen konnten, das alles wieder ordentlich zu machen.
Also, ich habe bisher nur Virenbefall, Ransomware und solche Geschichten mitbekommen für Windows-Clients,
für Windows-Server, nie für Linux-Server.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund, weshalb ich mich jetzt hier so ein bisschen verletzt fühle.
Für Windows-Clients, für Windows-Server, nie für Linux-Server und Linux-Systeme.
Wie gesagt, theoretisch kann das natürlich auch passieren, habe ich aber bisher noch nicht mitbekommen.
Natürlich, wenn du jetzt einen Windows-Share auf einem Linux-Server betreibst
und sich irgendein Windows-User, was anfängt, die gemountete Platte zu verschlüsseln,
ja, da würde ich aber nicht so weit gehen und sagen, das ist ein Virus, den sich der Linux-Server eingefangen hat,
also irgendein Windows-Client verschlüsselt hat Dateien.
Wobei man das auch teilweise schon ganz gut erkennen kann.
Es gibt ja Erkennungen so nach dem Motto, hier schreibt relativ viel random Zeug und sowas.
Aber trotzdem ist es natürlich schwierig.
Ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Irgendwelche Linux-Jump-Posts sind sicherlich sinnvoll.
Ich meine, wenn eure komplette Umgebung Windows ist, dann wird es euch ein Linux-Terminal-Server auch nicht bringen.
Außerdem braucht man ja gar keinen Linux-Terminal-Server, um sich ordentlich über Linux tunneln zu können.
Aber so ein SSH-Login dazwischen wirkt Wunder.
Natürlich stimme ich dir zu als Linux-Admin, dass das so ist.
Natürlich sind alle Linux-Admins mehr Firefighter als Windows-Admins, da sind wir uns ja einig.
Wie läuft die Lauferei?
Oh, ich bin relativ zackig mittlerweile, ich kann es dir sagen.
Warte mal, ich will euch jetzt nicht zu sehr damit vorlabern, aber gestern erst, gelaufen, pass mal auf.
Gestern erst, 44 Minuten, 6,1 Kilometer, durchschnittliche Herzfrequenz 157, durchschnittlicher Pace 7 Minuten 16 für einen Kilometer.
Ich habe angefangen mit 8 Minuten 30 vor zwei Wochen oder so.
Aber das liegt glaube ich jetzt auch daran nicht, dass ich so ultra viel fitter jetzt schon geworden bin,
sondern, dass ich mich einfach daran gewöhnt habe und auch ein bisschen, sag mal,
vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen mehr Muskel habe, was Wade und so angeht nach zwei Wochen,
sodass das Laufen einfach einfacher fällt.
Ich habe mir jetzt übrigens auch ein paar ordentliche Schuhe gekauft zum Laufen.
Ich bin ja vorher in meinen ganz normalen Turnschuhen gerannt,
die sind allerdings so gut wie gar nicht, wie heißt das auf Deutsch, abgefedert, glaube ich.
Weiß nicht, so Kaschen, die sind halt ziemlich, ziemlich hart von der Sohle her.
Die geben ein bisschen nach, aber halt wirklich nur relativ, relativ starr.
Ich habe mir jetzt ein paar Schuhe gekauft zum Laufen und ich muss sagen,
das ist was ganz anderes, das ist viel angenehmer.
Ich habe mir jetzt gekauft, ich habe mir so richtige fette Laufschuhe gekauft.
Also mit fett meine ich nicht unbedingt den Preis, der ist auch nicht billig,
sondern fette Polster, weil ich bin ja auch nicht der leichteste
und dann ist es eh schon ziemlich anstrengend für Muskel und Gelenke.
Wie heißt das Ding? So ein Teil, ja.
So ein Teil habe ich mir gekauft.
Barfuß kannst du vergessen.
Guckt mal, ihr müsst euch mal, guckt euch, guckt euch mal diese,
dieses Kissen an, was da drunter ist.
Gibt es, gibt es auch in allen möglichen.
Wo ist meiner hier? Das ist meiner.
Ja, nee, doch, doch.
Das da, 44.
Das Teil habe ich mir gekauft.
Allerdings nicht die Variante, sondern die gibt es, die gibt es auch in white.
Ich habe mir die in white gekauft, weil die anderen waren ein bisschen, bisschen, bisschen schmal.
Und das da unten ist halt quasi wie so ein Kissen, was du unten drunter hast.
Und als ich das erste Mal damit gelaufen bin, muss ich sagen,
das war echt ein Riesenunterschied.
Die erste Hälfte meiner Runde hat mich überhaupt nicht gestört.
Normalerweise habe ich das immer direkt gemerkt in den Waden,
im Oberschenkel und sonst wie, dass man das halt,
das war halt sehr hart aufgetreten, dass ich da entschuldige.
Ich habe die erste Hälfte der Runde nichts gemerkt.
Das war einfach nur extrem entspannt und angenehm.
Dann war ich zu doof und bin zu schnell weitergerannt,
weil es so easy lief und war dann übelst fertig nach der Runde.
Aber, aber okay.
So, und ein Problem, was ich, was ich, was ich, was ich habe,
aber ich glaube, das liegt an meinen Füßen.
Ein Problem, was ich habe, ich habe, ich laufe halt sonst,
also tagsüber und wenn ich renne und so,
nur in relativ harten Turnschuhen.
So im Vergleich zu denen und dementsprechend sind meine Füße
an so weichem Untergrund nicht gewöhnt.
Und ich habe das, ich habe das die erste, die ersten 2,
3 Kilometer übelst, übelst gemerkt,
dass sich mein Fuß voll verkrampft hat in dem neuen,
in den neuen Schuhen, obwohl der Schuh richtig fest war
und auch von der Größe her gut passt, voll verkrampft haben,
weil meine Füße das gar nicht gewohnt sind,
auf ein bisschen, so ein bisschen,
nicht ganz so hartem Untergrund zu stehen.
Aber es ging dann.
Man muss sich einfach nur drauf konzentrieren,
dass man entspannt läuft.
Es geht nicht darum, schnell zu rennen
oder nicht nur darum, schnell zu rennen,
sondern vor allem, dass das halbwegs schonend
und angenehm ist zu rennen.
Ja, das Teil in dieser Farbe,
also fühlt sich, fühlt sich mega entspannt an,
da drin zu laufen.
Mister Essen alive, danke schön für den Sub.
Also die ganze Zeit vorher,
also die ganze Zeit vorher hatte ich,
hatte ich wirklich ziemlich,
ziemlich harte Schuhe, also da hatte ich
irgendwie sowas.
Das sind halt so normale Turnschuhe,
die ich anhabe, ja.
Das sind so die richtigen Boomer-Schuhe.
160 gibt es sowas.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich jetzt für Schuhe anhabe,
aber welche, die nicht so gut,
nicht so schön gepolstert sind.
Das mag sein,
aber zum Rennen, ganz ehrlich,
es ist einfach mega angenehm gewesen
mit den Schuhen versus
den...
Also das ist wirklich super angenehm zu laufen.
Ich bin auch ein bisschen skeptisch,
wie lange das hält.
Laut Reviews soll das relativ lange halten,
also das wird ja immer so gesagt,
so was weiß ich,
du kannst so und so viele Kilometer rennen damit,
bis es dann...
Aber ich habe meine Zweifel,
wie lange das hält,
weil billig sind die Teile nicht,
wobei, wenn du dir die kaufst,
sind die ein bisschen billiger.
Ich habe, glaube ich, 140 Euro oder so
dafür bezahlt bei Amazon.
Ja, also der offizielle Preis
ist halt ein bisschen pp-iger.
Bei Amazon kostet das Ganze
einfach 60 Euro weniger.
Oder man kauft sich die Damen-Variante,
dann ist es noch billiger.
Die sind kleiner.
Ja, guck, hier 150.
Guck.
Das ist mal eine Fivehead-Farbe.
Naja.
Und es ist halt wirklich extrem angenehm
versus die anderen Schuhe.
So, aber genug.
Ah ja, ich wollte ja erzählen,
also ich bin jetzt
letztens, also meine aktuelle
Rekordrunde ist
7 Minuten 16
pro Kilometer.
So, und das sind
8,3
Kilometer die Stunde,
die man da
rennt.
So, mal gucken.
Ich werde das weitermachen. Ich renne weiter jeden zweiten Tag.
Ich muss sagen, mir macht das richtig Spaß
mittlerweile. Und ich mache ja auch noch
meine normale Runde. Also ich laufe
meine 6 Kilometer
alle 2 Tage
und dann gehe ich meine 1,5-2 Stunden
nachmittags ja noch
meine Wanderrunde machen.
Da habe ich genug Kalorienverbrauch
und auch genug Bewegung.
Also ich hatte gestern
die beiden Runden zusammen,
also zumindest hat das
meine Fitness-Tracker-Geschichte
ausgerechnet.
Ich habe so eine Uhr, die das misst,
was du für eine Pulsfrequenz und so hast.
Hatte ich mit beiden Runden zusammen
also
mittags 6 Kilometer
rennen oder 6,1 Kilometer rennen
und morgens 7,8
Kilometer wandern durch den Wald
habe ich über 1000
Kalorien verbraucht.
Das ist fast ein Drittel
vom Tagesbedarf.
Also das ist schon ordentlich.
Da muss man ordentlich
muss man ordentlich fressen, dass ich mein Gewicht halte.
Dafür habe ich mittags auch
krass viel gefressen, Alter.
Ich habe Nudeln
nicht mit Lachs, Leute. Einfach nur
Nudeln mit Hackfleisch.
Ich muss euch das jetzt mal zeigen.
Es gibt ja
einmal so Teller
und es gibt so Teller.
Und da ist
logischerweise viel mehr Platz
drin, weil bei gleicher Größe
hat so ein Teller halt nur hier so was.
So ein bisschen.
Und so ein Teller hat halt die komplette Fläche.
Und ich habe drei
Teller
nicht gehäuft, aber voll
mit Nudeln gefressen gestern Mittag,
weil ich so übertrieben Hunger hatte.
Ich habe mehr Tagesbedarf.
Ich bin dick.
In meiner Fitness Tracker App
habe ich eingegeben 93 Kilo.
Stimmt nicht so ganz. Es ist so im Durchschnitt
mal mehr, mal weniger.
Morgens nach dem Aufstehen sind es meistens 92.
Dafür sind es abends dann
93.
Ich habe 93 mal eingegeben.
Da verbraucht man ja allgemein mehr,
wenn man dick ist.
Wobei, so dick bin ich gar nicht mehr.
Vor zwei Jahren war ich mit
108,5, 109,
108.
In dem Dreh war eine ganze Ecke dicker.
Kein flacher Teller.
Nein, das meine ich nicht.
Ich meine keinen flachen Teller.
Es gibt Teller, die haben so einen Rand.
Und dann gibt es Teller,
die sind genauso groß,
haben aber hier keinen Rand, sondern gehen einfach runter.
Also nicht flach,
sondern sowas hier.
Guck.
Also ein Teller,
der quasi so groß ist wie der,
nur dass er hier direkt runter geht.
Dass der quasi nochmal so ein Drittel extra Fläche hat.
Und davon habe ich
11 voll mit Nudeln gefressen.
Da sind die Kalorien wieder drin.
Die haben keinen Griff, nö. Brauchst du ja auch nicht.
Das steht ja auch vor mir und dann geht es
reingestopft.
Ne, aus dem flachen Teller
kannst du ja nicht essen, da fallen ja die Nudeln
die ganze Zeit raus.
Und kleckerst du die Sauce,
das Hackfleisch und Tomatensauce auf den Tisch.
Ne.
Die haben keinen Griff. Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist eher was, im Restaurant möchte ich halt
auch nicht servieren müssen mit so einem Teller hier.
Naja.
Wie dem auch sei.
LeJark, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Es ist tatsächlich
eher so eine Art Schüssel.
Ich hatte übertrieben Hunger.
Ganz ehrlich,
das habe ich mir auch schon öfters überlegt.
Ich habe es noch nicht gemacht,
aber das habe ich mir auch schon öfters überlegt.
Warum nehme ich überhaupt noch einen Teller?
Ich meine, ich könnte einfach Nudeln kochen,
dann
in der Pfanne Hackfleisch Tomatensauce
und am Ende kippe ich einfach
Hackfleisch und Tomatensauce in die Schüssel.
Nicht in die Schüssel, in den Topf,
wo die Nudeln drin waren, rühre um und esse
was da draus. Also,
das müsste eigentlich sogar
am allereinfachsten sein.
Und ich hätte eine Portion auf einmal,
müsste nicht zwischendurch was holen.
Ja, das ist eigentlich ziemlich
Six-Head, wenn man sich das mal überlegt.
Du musst weniger sauber machen,
du verbrauchst weniger Wasser
und dann sparst du Geld.
Und du musst zwischendurch
nicht aufstehen und dir neues Zeug holen.
Und es wird,
es ist nicht dann eine Sache kälter,
als die andere und so. Das ist eigentlich super.
Eigentlich ist es extrem Six-Head.
Die Nudeln direkt aus dem...
Das einzige, wo das nicht so Six-Head ist,
wenn du zu viel gemacht hast, dass du es nicht alles packst.
Exzellent.
Wir waren aber eigentlich noch beim Hackerangriff
auf die Dänen hier.
Also, Windows-Systeme
haben ihr
Verschlüsselungs-Toyana-Zeug verteilt.
The Real Agent Smith ist am Start.
Bei deinem Namen fällt mir auf, ich muss unbedingt
mal wieder Matrix 1 gucken.
Ich sag absichtlich 1, weil alle anderen Filme naja sind.
Ich muss denn so alle
2-3 Jahre mal gucken.
Das ist einer meiner absoluten Lieblingsfilme.
Dadurch gelang es den Cyberkriminellen...
Ich find dieses Wort so geil
immer auf Deutsch.
Die Kriminalität.
Dadurch gelang es den Gottesabbild.
Prime ist abgelaufen.
Ja, ich war eine Weile nicht online.
Schon 5 Tage her.
Da kann man das schon mal vergessen.
Aber danke für den Sub.
Nee, also ernsthaft.
Ich weiß, dass ich die letzten Wochen
nicht so oft online war.
Liegt aber einfach daran,
erstens ist es auf der Arbeit recht anstrengend,
außerdem spiele ich nebenbei Baldur's Gate 3
und außerdem bewege ich mich jetzt auch noch mehr.
Und ich will noch ein bisschen Broggers Zeug
privat für mich machen.
Also sprich, schwierig,
falsches Emote.
Grad dann auch noch
ein paar Stunden zu streamen.
Aber das werde ich auch wieder tun.
Spätestens im Dezember gibt es wieder
komplette Content-Offensive.
Da bin ich den ganzen Dezember frei.
Aber das muss ich irgendwie
mal gucken, dass ich das alles auf die Reihe kriege.
Und ich muss ein Video aufnehmen.
Ich habe mir sogar schon ein paar Sachen zu aufgeschrieben.
Vielleicht mache ich das nach dem streamen gleich.
Infizierte Windows-Server.
Dadurch gelang den Cyberkriminellen
Zugriff auf alle Datenspeicher, Replikations-
Backup-Systeme und sekundäre Sicherungssysteme.
Okay.
Die bösartigen Akteure verschossen alle Serverlaufwerke,
die primären und die sekundären.
Dann stürzten die Rechner ab und hatten keinen Zugriff
mehr auf Daten.
Tja.
Pech gehabt.
Nicht aufgepasst.
Aber letztendlich
passieren kann immer irgendwas.
Hat man ja letztens wieder bei Microsoft gesehen,
die einfach einen ihrer
zentralen Tokens verloren haben und
dann nichts dazu gesagt haben.
Ja, aber Microsoft,
wir wissen doch gar nicht, ob nichts passiert ist.
Ne, ne. Glaubt uns mal.
Ist nichts passiert. Alles gut.
Rubico! 1337 Elite
hier am Start.
Danke für den Sub.
So, dann lasst uns mal schnell.
Ja, du meinst den hier.
Das hatten wir doch gerade. Cloud Nordic.
So.
Dann lasst uns doch mal schnell.
Ach ne, hier ist nichts trending.
Ich explore.
Lasst uns doch mal kurz gucken, was auf GitHub trendet.
Außer AI. AI. Ja, AI wird
geskippt.
Also, was ich euch sagen kann
ist,
ich habe es noch nie erlebt,
dass Linux-Server betroffen waren
immer nur Windows-Systeme.
Und bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber,
das habe ich euch ja schon mal ausführlicher erzählt,
aber dass man mal sieht, wie schnell es gehen kann.
Bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber hatten wir auch mal
ähnliche Probleme. Nicht in diesem Umfang.
Es ist nicht so, dass alle Server-Systeme und Storage-Systeme
und alle Backups und so verschlüsselt waren.
Aber aufgefallen ist es,
haltet euch mal fest,
aufgefallen, dass irgendwas nicht stimmt.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich euch das schon mal erzählt habe.
Also bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber aufgefallen,
dass es dort irgendwie so
ein kleines Viren-Trojaner-
Malware-Problem gibt
im Windows-Sektor.
Ist aufgefallen, weil,
jetzt haltet euch fest, jemand hat auf
einem Windows-Laufwerk sein entschlüsselten
Keypass-Safe als Textdatei gefunden.
Und da hat er sich gedacht,
da hat er sich gedacht, Moment,
warum ist
mein Keypass entschlüsselt auf dem Netzlaufwerk
in Plaintext?
Und daraufhin haben sie angefangen mal zu suchen,
was da los ist und es ist
aufgefallen, oh shit,
es gibt noch deutlich mehr Probleme.
Gab es sonst keine Alerts?
Nein, nichts, bis dahin
nicht aufgefallen.
So, ähm,
und,
ja, die Details will ich jetzt nicht
so erzählen, aber ich kann euch erzählen,
woher es gekommen ist.
Woher es gekommen ist, und zwar,
ich glaube, ich kriege das noch halbwegs richtig zusammen,
und zwar war die Einfalls...
Ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Wobei, jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Das war aber eine Zeit lang so, ja.
Hm, zumindest...
Na gut, du musst ja immer noch irgendwas
einfangen,
was den
RAM ausliest, ne, so einfach, nur weil
die im RAM liegen, landen die nicht auf einer Textdatei
im Windows-Share. Ich meine, der Chat
ist auch freilesbar und landet nicht
bei mir in einer Textdatei auf dem Windows-Share.
Hoffe ich zumindest.
Vielleicht ist ja mein Windows,
mein Share inoffizieller
Twitch-Backup-Server.
Hm. So,
also, ich kann euch aber erzählen, wo es hergekommen ist,
wo das Einfallstor war, und zwar,
wir hatten, sie hatten einen
SCP,
genau, so war das. Sie hatten einen
SCP-Server, also
ein...
wo du per
SSH und SCP Sachen draufkopieren
kannst, sie hatten einen
SCP-Server,
also einen Dateiaustauschserver
bereitgestellt, für
einen Dienstleister.
Allerdings sind sie auf die glorreiche
Idee gekommen, und jetzt haltet euch fest,
sie sind auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen,
den
Dateiaustauschserver, wo die Leute per SCP
draufkopiert haben, unter Windows
zu betreiben, nicht unter Linux.
Und das war schon das erste Problem.
Ich weiß nicht, warum man überhaupt
etwas für SSH-Logins unter Windows betreibt,
aber gut. Es war ein
oller Windows-Server,
mit irgendeinem SCP-Server,
frag mich nicht, was
benutzt man denn?
Was gibt's denn da unter Windows
überhaupt? Oh nein!
Im Zweifelsfall war das bestimmt
auch noch SolarWheels.
Das weiß ich gar nicht,
aber das würde natürlich passen, Alter.
Wobei, wahrscheinlich brauchst du das gar nicht.
Wahrscheinlich brauchst du das gar nicht,
weil du hast ja unter Windows...
Wobei, hast du da ein SSHD
mittlerweile drauf?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht. Zumindest war es ein
SCP-Server, wo du dich einloggen konntest.
Und das war ein
oller Windows, ein oller
SCP-Server,
und da waren irgendwelche Hackermans,
waren beim Dienstleister aktiv,
und die haben dann halt vom Dienstleister ausgeguckt,
wo sie hinkommen können, haben dann
das Einfallstor über diesen nicht richtig
gesicherten SCP-Server gefunden,
und das nächste
bin ich mir nicht mehr ganz so sicher. Also es kann auch sein,
dass jetzt ein bisschen Mist ist, was ich erzähle.
Zumindest hatten sie irgendwie die Möglichkeit,
dann ihre Berechtigung da drauf zu
eskalieren. Ich
weiß nicht mehr, wie das ging.
Es hat mir mal einer erzählt.
Das war relativ easy. Also entweder lief
der SCP,
der SCP-User
unter einem Admin-Account, oder
es war irgendwie eine andere Software
drauf, die unter einem Admin-Account
lief, oder ein alter
irgendwie ein temporäres
Session von einem Admin-Account.
Irgendwas. Ich weiß es nicht mehr
genau. Ich hab's mir auch
nicht genau gemerkt.
Zumindest hatten sie einen
Admin-Account, relativ schnellen Admin-Account,
für das ganze Active Directory.
Und dann haben sie über die Software-Verteilung
vom Active Directory
Keylogger und
Keypass
Passwort-Dumper
und so Zeug installiert.
Und dann hat irgendjemand sein Windows
Keypass-Dump auf dem Windows-Share
gefunden. Wir wissen nicht genau,
oder wussten damals nicht genau, wie lang die schon aktiv waren.
Wahrscheinlich nicht so lang, aber
bestimmt schon zwei, drei Tage.
Also im Zweifelsfall hätten die auch genug Zeit
gehabt, sehr viel abzusaugen.
Allerdings hatte mein alter Arbeitgeber da relativ
Glück im
Unglück.
Denn die
Hackermans haben das wohl gar nicht
so richtig realisiert, wo sie da gelandet sind.
Und
haben
das wohl auch nur automatisiert
halt alles
laufen lassen, ohne genauer zu gucken.
Also
es wurde höchstwahrscheinlich
nichts groß an Daten abgezogen.
Es wurde auch nicht versucht, sich auf
unsere Linux-Systeme und Datenbanken Zugriff zu
verschaffen. Das ist rein auf
Windows und hauptsächlich Client-Systemen
gewesen.
Und angeblich
haben sie die auch erwischt.
Hat man dann so ein halbes Jahr
später gehört, die Hackermans.
Ja, so sah das aus.
Also da war richtig die Kacke am Dampfen,
kann ich euch sagen. Und wisst ihr,
was gut war?
Dass
einzig und allein
unsere Linux-Laptops sicher waren
und unsere
Linux-Server sicher waren.
Das waren die einzigen Systeme, wo
wir davon ausgehen konnten, da ist nichts passiert.
Und das ging so weit,
das war witzig, das war echt lustig
mal zu sehen, weil die ganzen
Leute
da eher ein bisschen Linux-feindlich fast
schon eingestellt waren. So nach dem
Motto, wie ihr habt Linux-Notebooks,
das ist ja gar nicht im AD, das ist
ja voll unsicher. Und jedes
Mal, wenn das einer gesagt hat, habe ich dann nur noch
zu ihm gesagt
nach dem Vorfall.
Und
das war
insofern witzig, weil die ganzen
Leute, die dort dann, das ging ja über das
Wochenende, die ganzen Leute, die dort
dann über das Wochenende auch
aktiv waren, das alles wieder mit gefixt haben,
die haben sich dann
von uns Ubuntu-
USB-Sticks geholt und haben damit ihr Notebook
gebootet.
Die gleichen
Leute, die vorher auch immer ein bisschen erzählt haben,
so, Linux unsicher, weil nicht am
Active Directory angebunden.
Ach ja
und wisst ihr, was das Beste ist?
Das Beste,
ja, also
wisst ihr, was das Beste ist?
Aus dieser ganzen Story, das Fazit
daraus, wisst ihr,
übrigens war auch eines der Gründe, warum ich
noch weniger Bock hatte, dort zu bleiben, weil ich
total dämlich fand
und das konnte ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Also, wisst ihr, was
die Managemententscheidung daraufhin war?
Nachdem über
Windows-Sachen eingebrochen wurde,
wisst ihr, was die Managemententscheidung
gewesen ist, daraufhin?
Nein, nein, nein, ganz so
ganz, nein, nein, nein.
Die Managemententscheidung danach war,
wir installieren
jetzt auf allen unseren Systemen
Windows Defender,
auch auf Linux.
Also, wer das nicht weiß, es gibt
Windows Defender
für Linux. Also, gibt es.
Ja.
Also, wer denkt, das gibt es, das gibt es.
Das benutzt
keine Sau, aber das gibt es.
Daniel Lul, danke
für den Sub. Das gibt es.
Und das musste dann,
das musste dann auf allen Linux-Systemen
und Linux-Servern installiert werden.
Und,
wir sollten das dann auch auf unseren Linux-Notebooks
installieren. So.
Das wollte ich aber nicht.
Weil es mich übelst
abgefuckt hat, ja.
Und ich habe das dann einfach zwei Wochen oder so
ausgesessen und da hat sich nie jemand wieder drum gekümmert,
ob ich es installiert habe oder nicht.
Ja, das musste dann auf jedem Windows-Server
installiert werden. Und der hat regelmäßig
Probleme gemacht.
Unter Linux.
Also, das Ding
hat regelmäßig hohe CPU-Last
verursacht.
Und teilweise auf E-Mail-Systemen
den Dateizugriff ultra langsam
gemacht. Ja.
Und eines der Probleme
war, und das sollte
jeder wissen, der Microsoft Defender
für Linux, also auf Linux betreibt,
Microsoft kann den
Windows Defender ungefragt
updaten, solange das
System über ein Proxy irgendwie zu den
Microsoft-Servern kommt. Also,
das mag der ein oder andere
gut finden, weil es immer aktuelle
Virensignaturen hat, aber Microsoft
updatet darüber nicht nur die Virensignaturen,
Microsoft updatet darüber
auch Sachen im Windows Defender
selbst. Also, es kann sein,
dass von heute auf morgen auf einmal
Linux-Systeme, die komplett
unauffällig waren, bei euch auf einmal
80% CPU-Last haben und es kommt dann
raus, ah,
Microsoft hat nicht nur die Virensignaturen geupdatet,
sondern auch einen Patch eingespielt für
Windows Defender. Und es ist natürlich
sinnvoll, dass du die Systeme rauslässt
zu den Microsoft-Servern, dass sie sich
Virensignaturen ziehen können.
Also, echt hochgradig
fragwürdiger Shit, warum man das
auf Windows-Systemen installiert.
Nicht nur,
warte mal, nicht nur das,
die gleichen doch auch,
die suchen Passwörter
aus E-Mail-Verläufen
raus und vergleichen das
nicht auch mit irgendeiner Standard-Passwortliste ab und sowas.
Richtig, richtig
hängen geblieben.
So, aber lasst uns mal kurz gucken, was
Trended auf Shit hat.
AI, AI,
AI, nee.
Moment, ein MMO
in Rust?
Ah, nee.
React.
WebAssembly, oder doch
Rust? Rust?
Rust, Leute!
Blazingly Fast, written in Rust.
Ah, es ist so eine Art MMO
Minecraft mit
auf Rust-Basis.
Next.js TypeScript
React WebAssembly
Aha, was ist das?
China-Chinesen-Zeug?
Oh, Shit!
Was bin ich hier sehend?
What the fuck?
Moment, hat man das dann auf dem Desktop,
oder wie?
Alles klar.
Alles klar, das hat die Welt
gebraucht.
Kein Wunder, dass es
2,4 Tausend Sterne hat.
AI?
Terraform-Shit? Ja, weil HashiCorp
gesagt hat, die neuen Terraform-Versionen
sind jetzt
ähm, nee, nicht
Closed Source, sondern sind jetzt
irgendwie
eingeschränkt, dass man ihnen nicht mehr
damit Konkurrenz machen kann, oder sowas.
Weil ich das vielleicht ein bisschen
überreagiert finde, da was
zu forken, oder was das auch immer ist.
Ach nee, das ist bloß
irgendjemand hat einen Text geschrieben,
weil das eine doofe Idee ist.
AI, AI, AI,
AI, Flutter,
dum, dum, dum.
AI, AI, AI,
äh, nicht so spannend.
Gucken wir mal,
was sich hier getan hat.
AI,
AI, Avalonia.
Naja, okay.
Ups.
Nicht so spannend.
Eieiei.
Hast du schon mal im Stream was mit
HTMX gemacht? Nee.
Wollen wir das machen? Können wir machen.
Wir gucken uns ja öfters neues
Zeug an. Ich kenn das. Ich hab da letztens sogar
irgendwo ein Video drüber geguckt.
High-Power-Tools für HTML.
Ach, die Geschichte
war das. Ja, doch.
Können wir uns tatsächlich angucken.
Das haben wir schon gemacht.
Auch gemacht
haben wir.
Avalonia hatten wir uns
auch angeguckt. Das war doch ganz okay.
So.
Was haben
wir denn hier?
Power-Shuttle hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Hat denn einer von euch schon mal was mit
HTMX gemacht?
Chatgy?
Pfeifert Chatgy?
Bis jetzt bin ich ein bisschen
unschlüssig, wann und wozu
man das benutzen sollte.
Aber werden wir dann sehen.
Ich find den Namen ein bisschen unglücklich.
Go.
Okay, lass mal gucken.
Was haben wir denn hier auf YouTube?
Die absurde Welt der nordkoreanischen Influence.
Oh, Simplicissimus, da hab ich jetzt
keinen Nerv drauf. Immer.
Das sind keine schlechten Videos.
Das ist aber meistens so.
Jeder Satz hört sich da
immer so unglaublich wichtig ausgesprochen an.
Da muss ich mir erstmal ein paar andere Videos geben.
Bevor ich mir das
anhören kann.
Was ist das?
Discord Employees Review
working at Discord.
Die 10 besten
Shooter aller Zeiten. Wenn da Half-Life
1 nicht vorne dabei ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Chinaschrott. Was taugt
an 80 Euro 10 Gigabit Switch?
Okay. Oh.
Schreck mich nicht so.
Die deutsche Bahn macht auf dicke Hose im Internet.
Fireship. Fireship ist auch immer
nice.
Was hat die CT wieder am Start?
Der erste Videocall war schon 1927.
Ernsthaft?
1927? Das war vorm 2. Weltkrieg.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man dort
überhaupt schon ein Video aufnehmen konnte.
Hat da irgendjemand Fotos geschossen
und die mit einem
Frame pro Tag
weiter verschickt oder wie?
Wie soll 1927 Videocall
ausgesehen haben?
Foto bei Brieftaube.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal an.
Bin gespannt.
Guck mal hier.
So sah ein Videotelefonat
1936 aus.
Das ist die Nazi-Deutschland
gebaute sogenannte Fernseh-Sprechstelle.
Okay. Deutscher kann sich
das Ganze aber nicht mehr anhören, oder?
Guck mal hier.
So sah ein Videotelefonat
1936 aus.
Naja.
Das ist doch gar nicht mal so übel, oder?
Ich meine, guck mal.
Es scheint ein
halbwegs live Bild
zu sein.
Also für 1936 erscheint mir das
gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Ich meine, alles rein analoge Übertragungstechnik
hat wahrscheinlich gerauscht.
Es war eine niedrige Auflösung.
Vielleicht ist es doch einfach
nur irgendwie Nazi-Propaganda
und das ist ein Foto und gar kein
bewegtes Bild.
Man weiß es ja nicht.
Aber
wenn das so funktioniert hat,
ich meine, Telefon hat damals auf jeden Fall
funktioniert und
Kameras gab es damals
wahrscheinlich auch
schon. Gab es damals
Bildschirme? Ja, klar.
Ich meine, es gab Schwarz-Weiß-Filme und so.
Ähm.
Auch
Geschichte, Fernseh.
Guck.
1838.
Ab 1950 dann zum
Massenmedium. Jaja, das gab es schon.
Das war aber alles noch relativ neu.
Aber ich meine, für 1936?
Nicht schlecht.
Das ist die
Nazi-Deutschland-gebaute
sogenannte Fernseh-Sprechstelle.
Der Name ist halt so.
Deutscher kann es nicht mehr heißen.
Fernseh-Sprechstelle.
Die Verbreitung dieses Geräts ist den Nazis
ebenso wenig gelungen wie der Rest ihrer Ideen.
Das war wahrscheinlich.
Also dass das sich damals nicht verbreitet hat,
lag wahrscheinlich auch schlicht und ergreifend
am Preis und an der nicht
vorhandenen Infrastruktur dafür.
BigBlueButton? Hatte jemand schon mal
die Ehre BigBlueButton verwenden zu müssen?
BigBlueButton.
Ja?
Wie ist das so?
Ich kenne das immer nur
von Screenshots oder von irgendwelchen Leuten,
die darüber ablästern.
Wir hatten BigBlueButton
an der Berufsschule. Absolut Kacke.
Okay.
Das reiht sich ungefähr in die Berichte ein,
die ich auch immer gehört habe,
dass es halt Schrott sein muss.
Ich würde mich halt interessieren, warum das
besser als Zoom?
Ja, Zoom finde ich auch ganz grenzwertig.
Wobei, ich finde, Zoom geht irgendwie noch.
Also ich musste letztens auf der Arbeit
mal in einen Zoom-Call joinen
mit dem Browser, weil irgendein
Dienstleister uns was anpreisen wollte
und das war
ein Zoom-Call.
Das ging eigentlich recht gut klar.
Ist BigBlueButton self-hosted?
Kann man das selbst
hosten? Ja, wobei hat da gerade jemand im Chat geschrieben.
Ist das Open Source auf GitHub?
ShitHub?
Complete Open
Source Web Conferencing System.
Na, das ist doch auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Pluspunkt
dafür. Auf was basiert
das denn?
Auf was basiert denn das im
Backend? Bestimmt Java
oder sowas.
Ja, auf was basiert das denn
im Backend?
Java wahrscheinlich.
Das ist ja eine wilde
Mischung, Alter. Javascript,
Scala, Ruby, TypeScript,
bisschen Bash und Others.
Ruby!
Das sieht eher wie was aus, wenn du keinen
Durchblick hast, wie du es gescheit
installieren sollst.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal das Video fertig an.
Videotelefonie ist heute allgegenwärtig,
aber die Entwicklung hat fast 100
Jahre gedauert. Aber,
seriously, so flüssig
in so guter
Qualität
ist bei den wenigsten
Videokonferenzen mittlerweile.
Also die meisten Leute haben irgendeine miese
Webcam, miese Beleuchtung, 5 FPS
und ihr Mikrofon im Poppis
stecken. Also,
das kann gut sein, ja.
Aber, also
gerade auch Teams, ich weiß
gar nicht, ob Teams überhaupt
50 oder 60 FPS
Videostreams übertragen kann.
Hat fast 100 Jahre gedauert.
Hier, das ist aus dem Jahr 1927.
Ein Testanruf zwischen Washington
und New York. Und zwei Jahre später
auf dem IFA-Vorgänger in Berlin wurde
auch mit Bild telefoniert. Allerdings nur mit
einem Abstand von wenigen Metern. Ja, und ein paar
Jahre später hat dann die Reichspost in
Deutschland die Fernsehsprechstelle auf
den Markt gebracht. Und damit die weltweit
ersten Videotelefone für
Ist das Vorgänger
von der Telekom? Für die Allgemeinheit.
Also hätte eure Uroma
damals schon Facetimen können? Ja, im Prinzip
ja. 1936 gab es schon
BigBlueButtonOrg. Okay.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Wobei, wenn ich da auf Demo klicke, wird bestimmt
mein IP oder so angezeigt. Sekunde,
muss ich grad mal auf dem zweiten Bildschirm ausprobieren.
Demo.
Ey, der Demo-Button geht bei mir nicht.
Ach, jetzt schon.
Sign up, sign in.
Ne, kann man nicht.
Aber ich...
Deine IP habt ihr schon. Okay, Chat.
Da stand gerade not secure.
Warum gehen die
HTTPS?
Jetzt ist es secure. Die haben kein
Redirect auf HTTPS.
Cringe!
Wer hat denn sowas nicht?
Verbindungen zwischen großen deutschen Städten
und die waren zwar teuer, aber tatsächlich
für alle benutzbar. Nur war das
vor allem Propaganda und nie
wirklich als Massenkommunikationsmedium
gedacht. Bis es das wurde, hat es noch ein
paar Jahrzehnte und eine Pandemie
gebraucht. Wir schauen uns heute mal an,
wie das damals... Ja gut, ich weiß nicht, ob man das
Propaganda nennen kann. Es kommt ja, es wird ja
oft neue Technik angepriesen
als
ja, kommt nächstes Jahr und dann
dauert es noch 15 Jahre so.
Ich meine, überlegt euch mal,
wie oft wurde jetzt erzählt,
das Ja des
Linux-Desktops... Ups, falscher
Kopf. Wie oft wurde
erzählt, das Ja des Linux-Desktops
oder
VR-Brillen
und sowas ist jetzt Mainstream
und so. Das ist bis jetzt auch noch nicht
passiert.
Und wie es dann ab den 70er Jahren
weiterging mit dem Thema Videotelefons.
Es wurde für Propaganda...
Gut, dann ist es so ähnlich, wie wenn Nordkorea
irgendwie
zeigt... Hatten sie nicht letztens?
Hatte nicht Nordkorea letztens
irgendeinen... Was war denn...
Nee, nee, nee, nicht Nordkorea.
Der Irak. Der Irak hatte doch
letztens so ein Spezial...
so ein super Spezial-Chip
gezeigt, der aus irgendwelchen
billig China-Chinesen-Teilen bestanden hat.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was das war.
Oder Iran, ja? Was war
das nochmal? Weiß das noch einer von euch?
Was war das denn? Die haben irgendwas...
Irgendwas
gezeigt, wo sie...
Was angeblich super
bahnbrechend war und es war es halt dann auch nicht,
wie vermutet.
Quantencomputer, irgendwie sowas.
Keine Ahnung.
Wo wusste man eigentlich das? Übrigens, so Telefone
in der Richtung...
Also jetzt mal
ohne Videokonferenz-Gedöns.
Aber Telefone in der
Richtung damals war
ich voll begeistert von, so
in dem Dreh 1997. Da gab es dann
ISDN. Und ich dachte,
ich dachte damals, ISDN
ist die Zukunft. Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
1997 hat man das gedacht.
Aber
kurz darauf gab es dann DSL,
weil man ja festgestellt hat,
dass ISDN ja eine coole Sache für
Telekommunikation ist, aber mega
schlecht für Internet.
ISDN war überhaupt nicht für Internet
ausgelegt. Man konnte darüber natürlich Datenübertragung
machen,
aber es war nicht auf Geschwindigkeit
ausgelegt oder auf Bahnbreite
ausgelegt.
Und ich hätte
damals ganz im Ernst
nicht gedacht,
also hätte mich 1997
jemand gefragt, hätte ich
garantiert nicht gesagt,
dass analoge Telefonie
länger
überlebt als ISDN.
Wobei man ja fairness halber
sagen muss, es ist ja eh ganz anders
gekommen, als man damals gedacht hat.
Es sieht ja nur noch aus, nach
analoger Telefonie. Es ist ja gar keine
analoge Telefonie mehr.
Also damals so ein ISDN-Telefon,
ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, sieht auch so ein bisschen
aus wie ein RJ45-Stecker.
Wobei, wenn ihr mich fragt,
das ist ein RJ45-Stecker.
Ja.
ISDN-Kabel, das war ein RJ45-Stecker.
Nee, nee, die normalen
Telefone sind etwas schmaler.
Die ISDN-Stecker waren RJ45-Stecker.
Relativ sicher, ja.
Das ist so ein normaler,
analoger, und das ist ein
ISDN.
Und heute benutzt
du ja wieder die analogen Telefonstecker
von früher, nur mit dem
Unterschied,
dass es halt spätestens
beim Provider
eVoIP ist
und höchstwahrscheinlich schon ab
deiner Fritzbox aus oder ab deinem
Router aus VoIP ist.
Also insofern, ja,
die letzten paar Meter sind
analoge, uraltechnik,
aber trotzdem, ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass das
sich länger hält als ISDN
für Festnetzgeräte.
Aber ist so.
Damals hat man, heute kannst du ISDN-
Festnetzgeräte gar nicht mehr anschließen.
Damals hast du noch
ein NTBA gebraucht,
ein NTBA,
hier, so ein Teil hast du damals noch
gebraucht, und das war, genau,
so ein Setup hast du damals
gebraucht. Du musstest
hier in deinen Hausanschluss,
das ist ganz wichtig bei der
Telekom, immer die erste TAE-Dose,
das kann auch sein, dass hier mal ein Telekom-Techniker
danach fragt, hast du
dann hier angeschlossen,
du konntest das auch hier drauf klemmen,
wenn du wolltest, und man konnte,
und das ist übrigens ein blödsinniges Bild,
normalerweise hast du dein ISDN
hier neben dran gestöpselt, oder halt,
ja okay, wenn du intern
das verlängern wolltest. Das coole bei ISDN
war, ich glaube, du konntest bei ISDN ja theoretisch
bis zu 8 Geräte
oder sowas anschließen. Die meisten
hatten nur 2, weil es halt der NTBA
2-Stecker hatte, und richtig
abenteuerlich wurde das ganze Setup dann
mit DSL und noch einem Splitter dabei.
Dann sah das nämlich so aus.
Das,
das, für mich ist das
noch das normalste der Welt.
Viele Leute kennen das heute gar nicht mehr.
Du hast
den Splitter eingestöpselt
in deine TAE-Dose,
das ist da, wo früher analoges Telefon dran war.
In den Splitter kam dann auf der
einen Seite, hier vorne, kam der
NTBA rein, hier unten kam dann
DSL-Modem rein. Und was das gemacht hat,
das hat
die Frequenzen quasi gesplittet.
Das fragt mich nicht.
Ich glaube, das untere Frequenzbereich war
für ISDN, und das obere Frequenzbereich
war für DSL.
Und der hat das aufgeteilt,
hier zu DSL, da zu NTBA, und hier
ist dann dann ISDN-Zeug angeschlossen. Also damals
war Telefonie
und Internet tatsächlich noch komplett
getrennt. Und ISDN
hatte ja auch quasi komplett eigene
Telefonie-Funktionen. So mit
Anrufweiterleitung, Anrufhalten,
Konferenzschaltung und so. Das, was
heute jeder mit irgendwelchen VoIP-Clients oder
Teams oder so macht, war ja vieles in
ISDN schon eingebaut. Und ich hab damals halt echt gedacht,
ISDN ist halt voller krasses
Shit. Und sogar in der
Berufsschule, sogar in der
Berufsschule gab es noch ein bisschen
was über ISDN zu hören.
Allerdings nicht viel
danach wollte die Telekom ja gar kein
ISDN mehr verkaufen.
Also ich glaube so ab 2012,
13 oder so,
na gut, das ist doch schon eine ganze Weile nach der Berufsschule
gewesen dann,
hat die Telekom ja gesagt, sie wollen kein
ISDN mehr verkaufen. Und mittlerweile kannst du
glaube ich gar kein ISDN mehr.
ISDN-Telefon, äh...
Gibt es überhaupt noch?
Macht irgendjemand?
Das ist doch bestimmt kein echtes ISDN mehr, oder?
Das ist doch auch VoIP
mit irgendeinem Box.
Ja, das ist irgendeine Box, wo du ISDN
anschließen kannst, aber dahinter ist das ganz normale
VoIP.
Ja, das gibt es noch.
Du kriegst ja auch heute noch Fritzboxen mit
ISDN-Anschlüssen und sowas.
Ja, so hast du damals
dein, ups,
so hast du damals dein
Home-Setup angeschlossen.
Ja, und wenn du kein ISDN
hattest...
Leute, wer weiß es noch?
Wo hast du hier dein Telefon angeschlossen,
wenn du kein ISDN hattest?
Aber wieso solltest du heute noch?
Weiß ich auch nicht.
An den Splitter, richtig.
Dein Telefon hast du da vorne reingesteckt.
Wenn du kein ISDN hattest...
Warum man das heute machen sollte,
keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, und ich dachte halt, das war richtig, richtig
moderner Shit damals.
1997 hätte ich im Leben
nicht gedacht, dass es mal
das analoge Telefonie,
sagen wir mal, länger überlebt als ISDN.
Wirklich analog ist es ja heute auch nicht mehr.
Aber so die letzten, die letzten
paar Meter, wenn man ein Festnetztelefon
hat, die letzten paar Meter
Kabel, bei manchen kommt dann auch Deck
dahinter, aber
die letzten paar Meter Kabel sind
heute bei ganz vielen Leuten mit einem Festnetztelefon
ganz normale
Oldschool 1900er
Telefontechnik.
Analoges
2A-Kabel,
also nicht, alle Kabel sind analog,
2A, dann Kabel,
analoge Telefonzeug drüber.
Wer hat heute noch ein Festnetztelefon?
Ich hab noch ein Festnetztelefon. Ich benutze das zwar nicht,
aber ich hab noch eins.
Ich hab noch, ich hab ein Fritz-Phone.
Sogar zwei, eins
im ersten Stock und eins im Erdgeschoss stehen.
Aber ich benutze das so gut wie nie.
Meine Mutter benutzt das aber.
Die telefoniert irgendwie nur
mit dem Festnetztelefon. Ich keine Ahnung.
Obwohl ich der, obwohl ich der
vor paar Jahren
einen iPhone SE geschenkt hab,
und jetzt
mittlerweile hat sie sogar einen iPhone
10, glaube ich.
Also insofern,
ja, aber das ist halt
noch mehr Boomer.
Die bringt das nicht
im Kopf zusammen, dass sie genauso gut
mit dem Handy telefonieren könnte, als mit dem Festnetz.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Aber damals dachte ich so, Telefone
ist der moderne, krasse Scheiß.
Damals hast du dich auch
übelst gefeiert. Da hat sie dann
so Spezialfunktionen auf dem
Telefon.
Wie zum Beispiel
T-Netbox
einschalten und so.
Kennt das noch jemand?
T-Netbox?
Das war der Anrufbeantworter
von der Telekom.
Das ist quasi in der Cloud gehostet.
Der damals schon in der Cloud gehostete
Anrufbeantworter
von der Telekom.
Ich habe heute gar keinen Anrufbeantworter mehr.
Anrufbeantworter ist total out.
Die Leute sollen mich auf dem Handy anrufen. Entweder gehe ich dran oder nicht.
Fertig aus.
Schnellwahltasten und sowas.
Ich muss es euch jetzt
nochmal zeigen. Wahrscheinlich ist es eine Recycled Story.
Ich habe es euch bestimmt schon mal gezeigt.
Und ich habe das.
Ich habe dieses Ding auch noch irgendwo.
Ich habe das nämlich mitgenommen beim Umzug.
Weil das ist so ein Ding, das behalte ich,
bis ich irgendwann mal den Löffel abgebe, weil ich das Gerät
so nice finde.
Und zwar, ich hatte damals als Modem
ein Elsa
Mikro Link Office.
Und dieses Teil,
Alter,
da geht mir heute noch
einer drauf ab, weil das so
eines meiner
ersten Technikgeräte war,
wo ich so richtig begeistert von war,
was das alles kann.
Also,
das war ein 56k Modem.
Allerdings, nicht einfach
nur ein 56k
Modem. Man sieht es ja hier teilweise.
Nein, das war,
jetzt haltet euch fest, das war einmal
ein 56k Modem.
Ich glaube, hier sieht man es.
Hier sieht man es. Ja, hier sieht man es eigentlich ganz
gut auf dem Bild. Exzellent.
Guck mal, das war nicht nur ein
56k Modem,
das hatte,
das hatte integrierten Anrufbeantworter
und, und,
Leute, und
Fax. Und nicht etwa
einfach nur, dass du damit Fax verschicken konntest.
Nein, das hatte integrierten
Speicher. Da konntest du
Telefonanrufe aufnehmen drauf
und Faxe
empfangen drauf, ohne, dass
du ein Faxgerät brauchtest.
Du hattest quasi ein Gerät, was immer
an war, Faxe
empfangen konnte und du konntest dir dann die Faxe auf dem Computer
angucken und auch auf dem Computer Faxe
schicken, ohne, dass du ein Faxgerät
brauchtest. Das war richtig geil damals.
Weil
Faxgeräte sind also richtig dumm und stehen in der
Gegend rum, bekommen Fax,
fassen es dann aus und sowas. Richtig dämlich.
Und damals schon
mit Speicher intern.
Ja, Fritzbox, keine.
Leute, damals gab es doch keine Fritzbox.
Dazu konntest du damit auch am Rechner
telefonieren. Ja.
Rechner telefonieren. Guck mal, du
konntest, siehst du ja auch hier, du konntest direkt anschließen
Mikrofon und sowas.
Du konntest damit telefonieren.
Du konntest am Rechner telefonieren.
Du konntest damit Faxe verschicken, Faxe empfangen,
Anrufe,
Aufzeichner als Anrufbeantworter,
alles mit ihnen und als Modem benutzen.
Telefonanschluss
und so auch. Das war damals richtig nice.
Das sind
Knöpfe, das sind keine Stecker, das sind Knöpfe.
Du konntest hier zum Beispiel
vorspulen, zurückspulen auf dem
Anrufbeantworter. Du konntest
nächste Nachricht anhalten,
nächste Nachricht
Fax an- und ausschalten, Nachricht
löschen. Du konntest Anrufbeantworter
Ansage aufnehmen
oder du hast hier drauf gedrückt
und dann hat es dir gesagt
sie haben 5 Nachrichten
und sowas. Das hat dann auch vorne
dementsprechend geplinkt
wenn du Faxe
hattest.
Es ist mir immer suspekt, wenn
Internetseiten nicht richtig Mimetypes haben.
Ja, guck du hattest
hier vorne auch einen Plinker
für Voice Nachrichten sind da oder Faxe sind
eingegangen und da ging mir immer richtig
drauf ab, das hat grün geplinkt
so schnell. Immer richtig drauf ab, wenn
dann Voice Nachrichten geplinkt haben.
Da konnte man sich das anhalten.
Also, das
da bin ich richtig drauf abgegangen
damals. Das war auch ziemlich teuer für die damalige
Zeit. Ich glaube das hat
150 Mark oder so gekostet. Ich weiß,
jetzt höre ich mich an wie der übelste Opa
aber das war halt 1997.
So in dem Dreh.
Richtiges Poggers Teil.
Ach ja, Chat.
Wie hat man das
eigentlich an den Computer angeschlossen?
Das hier war ein Ein- und Ausschalter.
Angeschlossen hast du
über serielle Schnittstelle an den Computer.
Und jetzt haltet euch mal fest.
Ratet mal, ohne nachzugucken.
Ratet mal, wie viel
internen Flashspeicher
dieses Modem hatte 1997.
Wie viel internen Speicher hat es gehabt?
Wohlgemerkt für
Sprachnachrichten und für Faxe.
1 MB? Nee.
Nein.
Ich glaube es hatte 4 MB.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das hier steht.
4 MB hatte das.
Chipforum
2002.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es 4 MB
Flashspeicher hatte.
Aber muss man sich mal überlegen, mit 4 MB
konnte man damals einige
Sprachanrufe schon aufnehmen. Die Qualität
könnt ihr euch dementsprechend vorstellen.
Geil.
Aber man hat alles verstanden.
Das habe ich immer noch irgendwo.
Das werde ich nie wegschmeißen.
Das war eines meiner Lieblingsgeräte.
Leute, habe ich es ernsthaft
geschafft, 1 Minute 12
Videos zu gucken und dazu jetzt eine halbe Stunde zu reden?
Oder wie?
Standard.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir uns das aber fertig an.
Warum es nie jemand wirklich benutzen wollte,
was heute zum Standard in der täglichen
Kommunikation wurde. Bleibt dran.
Lieber Hackerin, lieber
Internetsurfer, herzlich willkommen hier.
Bye.
Also die Erfindung
des Telefons hat damals ein bisschen
was verändert. Surprise.
Aber eine kurze Zeit, nachdem sich
Alexander G. Bell 1876
das Telefonpatent gesichert hat,
kamen erst Ideen zum Videotelefon auf.
Ganz wichtig dabei, es gab damals
ja auch noch keinen Fernseher.
Die ganzen Gedanken rund um Videotelefonie
sind Hand in Hand mit Gedanken rund um
das Medium Fernsehen gegangen.
Also sowas wie Live-Übertragung von Sportveranstaltungen
oder Nachrichten. Heute voll normal.
Damals der neue, richtig heiße
Scheiß. Und wahrscheinlich hat das die Menschen
damals ähnlich fasziniert wie uns
heute generative KI-Modelle.
Und genau deswegen wurde da auch intensiv dran gearbeitet.
Und zwar zeitgleich in den USA,
in Deutschland und auch in Frankreich.
Es gab viele Ideen, wie das Medium
Videotelefonie die Kommunikation
verändern könnte. Zum Beispiel hier.
Das ist eine Karikatur aus dem Jahr 1879
und ja, das trifft schon ziemlich gut,
wie Videotelefonie vor einem großen
Bildschirm heute aussieht. Ja ok, die Mikrofone
sind anders als die Lautsprecher.
Aber sonst sieht das...
Wahrscheinlich waren die Mikrofone und Lautsprecher besser
als das, was die Leute heute haben.
Sieht heute doch genauso aus, wenn ich im Wohnzimmer
vom Fernseher Videotelefonie mache.
Ja, und auch diese Illustration aus dem Jahr 1910.
Das ist halt schon
ein bisschen antik, ja?
Aber guck mal, mit Beamer.
Das macht bestimmt der ein oder andere mit Beamer.
Ja, kann man mal machen.
Und auch im Kino wurden...
Aber guck mal, wie krass
gechillt er da sitzt.
Aus dem Jahr 1910.
Ja, kann man mal machen.
Und auch im Kino wurden natürlich
Videotelefonate gezeigt. Einmal hier
1925 im US-amerikanischen Film
Up the Ladder und in Deutschland
zwei Jahre später im Film
Metropolis wird eine Industriestadt
aus dem Jahr
2026 gezeigt.
Und hier benutzt der Meister ein Videotelefon...
2026?
Das ist ja in drei Jahren.
...zum Vorarbeiter zu sprechen.
Insgesamt...
Ja, das ist halt blöd bei den ganzen Science-Fiction-Filmen von früher.
Da haben die auch gedacht, dass wir 2000 schon
fliegende Autos haben und sowas.
...hat das Thema in den 1920er-Jahren
an Fahrt aufgenommen.
Einmal hier in den USA, da seht ihr, wie
1927 das erste Telefonat mit
Video stattgefunden hat. Zwischen dem damaligen
US-Wirtschaftsminister Herbert Hoover
und dem AT&T-Chef.
Also, wenn man das überhaupt Videotelefonie nennen
möchte. Denn das Video war mehr so
ein Begleitbild und vor allem auch
einseitig. Also es konnten sich nicht beide gleichzeitig
sehen. Also mehr so ein Tech-Showcase,
der der anwesenden Journalistengemeinde
zeigen sollte, wie weit man schon bei
der Entwicklung war. Das Videosignal
wurde über eine extra Leitung gesendet
und war mit 18 Bildern pro Sekunde
auch nicht wirklich flüssig.
Ja, da habe ich schon
schlechteres gesehen, auch heute.
Zumindest nach heutigen Standards. Heute haben
filmische Bewegungen mindestens 24 Bilder.
Also aber 18 FPS für ein
Webcam-Video,
da habe ich schon mehr Geruckel gesehen.
Richtig los mit der Videotelefonie
ging es aber tatsächlich in Deutschland.
Hier wurde 1929 auf der
sechsten großen deutschen Funkausstellung
in Berlin, dem IFA-Vorgänger,
ein Prototyp einer Videotelefonanlage
gezeigt. Aber auch wenn sich die Leute
damals in zwei Kabinen, die wenige Meter
voneinander entfernt waren, gesehen und gehört
haben, es gibt heute leider keine Bilder
mehr davon, nur Texte.
Dem Entwickler Gustav Krawinkel
ging es damals vor allem darum, den Menschen
zu zeigen, dass Telefonie einen
wichtigen visuellen Teil der menschlichen
Kommunikation außen vor lässt. Das Problem war
damals aber, dass die Technik mit dem
mechanischen Lochabtaster, also der
Kamera, nicht mit den höherzeiligen
Fernsehnormen kompatibel war, weil der Abtaststrahl
deutlich heller gestellt werden
musste und damit die Nutzer und Nutzerinnen
zu sehr geblendet hätte und dadurch das
relativ dunkle Glimmlampenbild
gar nicht mehr sichtbar gewesen wäre. Und
deswegen wurde diese Technik dann erstmal
auf Eis gelegt. Aber ihr wisst,
1933 begann dann ein sehr
dunkles Kapitel der deutschen Geschichte
und für die Nazis war das Fernsehen
und die... Die hatten andere Sachen
favorisiert, was
Technologie angeht, nicht so sehr
Videoübertragung. Videotelefonie aus
Propagandazwecken so interessant, um der
Welt die von Zeit nicht technologische
Stärke zu präsentieren, dass die Forschung
daran intensiviert wurde. Ja und dann
gab es... Ah, Systema! Hätte ich jetzt...
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich umgedreht erwartet, ich hätte gedacht,
ist jetzt erstmal gar nichts passiert bis nach dem 2.
Weltkrieg, weil die halt eben andere Prioritäten
hatten. 1936
mit der Fernsehsprechstelle tatsächlich
das weltweit erste kommerzielle
Videotelefonsystem. Auf der Leipziger
Frühjahrsmesse konnte die Öffentlichkeit
den Vorläufer von unseren
heutigen Videokonferenzsystemen sehen.
Dort wurde auch der erste Anruf
zwischen Leipzig und Berlin gemacht
und natürlich für Propagandazwecke
missbraucht. Ja, was sonst? Kurz danach war
das System für alle, die bereit waren, dafür
zu bezahlen, zugänglich. Nicht zu Hause,
sondern in ausgewählten Reichspostämtern
in Leipzig, Berlin,
später auch Nürnberg, München und Hamburg.
Dort gab es extra Räume, die mit einem
Bildschirm und einem Telefon ausgestattet waren.
So eine Frisur
hatte meine Oma auch, als sie jung war.
...gestattet waren. Technisch hat das...
Da gibt's noch Bilder von. Das war damals wohl voller Trend.
...das Ganze im Wesentlichen über
die damalige Fernsehtechnik funktioniert.
Ein Jahr davor, 1935, ging in
Deutschland der Fernsehprogrammbetrieb
über Breitbandkabel an den Start.
Die Technik wurde unter anderem für die Übertragung
der Olympischen Spiele 1936
in Berlin eingesetzt. Die Fernsehsprechstelle
machte Übertragung mit
180 Zeilen bei 25
Bildwechseln pro Sekunde möglich. Der
Bildschirm dieser Fernsehsprechstelle hatte damals
die Maße von 20 x 20 cm an.
Von der Qualität...
Naja...
20 x 20...
Das geht doch irgendwie sogar.
Peter hat das dann so ausgesehen.
Zum Vergleich, dieses Video hat 4K-Auflösung,
also 2160
Bildzeilen. Das sind also 12 Mal...
Naja, man darf nicht vergessen,
das hier...
Das hier muss ja auch auf
einem Bildschirm dargestellt werden, der...
Oh ja...
Ungefähr so ist, hä?
Na gut, das passt jetzt nicht bei euch überein,
sonst kommt ein Bildschirm...
Und dann sieht es doch wiederum relativ
brauchbar aus. Ist doch vollkommen
okay, ja?
Von der Qualität her hat das dann so ausgesehen.
Zum Vergleich, dieses Video hat 4K-Auflösung,
also 2160
Bildzeilen. Ja, und wir gucken es nur in 1080p.
Nee, 1440p.
Das sind also 12 Mal so viel wie bei der
Fernsehsprechstelle. Heißt, selbst im Vergleich
zu einem normalen, heute relativ kleinen
32-Zoll-Fernseher waren die
Bildschirme in der Fernsehsprechstelle
quasi winzig. Neben der
Bildübertragung brauchte man auch noch eine extra
Telefonleitung, sodass beide Gesprächspartner
sich gesehen und gehört haben. Das hat dann
für ein 3-Minuten-Gespräch 3 Reichsmark
plus 50 Pfennig Gebühr gekostet.
Doppelt so viel wie ein normales
Telefonat damals. Laut dem Statistischen
Bundesamt würde das im Jahr 2022
einer Kaufkraft von fast
17 Euro entsprechen. Und ich sag mal
so, wenn man den technischen Aufwand dahinter
sieht, war das eigentlich günstig, aber
natürlich trotzdem sehr viel Geld.
Damit blieb der Erfolg aus. In Hamburg
zum Beispiel sollen nur 20 Verbindungen
über die Fernsehsprechstelle erfolgt sein.
In Nürnberg rund 10 Verbindungen
pro Monat. Problematisch war neben den
hohen Gebühren vor allem auch die Tatsache, dass man
ja nicht einfach jemanden anrufen konnte, sondern sich
irgendwie dafür verabreden musste.
Und erstmal eine Person finden musste,
die in der anderen Stadt geradet.
Ich mein, ein bisschen Ältere unter
euch werden das noch kennen. Früher,
wenn man in den Urlaub gefahren ist, ist man
dort auch erstmal an den Telefon
und hat bei Oma und Opa angerufen und hat gesagt,
man ist gut angekommen. Also wenn man im Hotel
war, ist man erstmal raus, hat irgendein Telefon
gesucht, hat
Münzen reingeschmissen, hat dann
daheim angerufen und hat gesagt, ja, alles gut
gelaufen, wir sind jetzt da.
Das ist nicht so nach dem Motto mit
lass uns mal kurz am Flughafen
noch eine SIM-Karte fürs Handy holen und
let's go.
Deshalb sollen viele Gespräche zum Ausprobieren
auch mit Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern
der Postämter geführt worden sein.
1940 wurde der Dienst
dann eingestellt, unter anderem auch
um die bestehenden Verbindungen exklusiv
militärisch nutzen zu können und
dann war ja erstmal Krieg und damit auch
die Weiterentwicklung des Videotelefons
hinten angestellt. Zwar hat der
US-amerikanische Kommunikationsanbieter
AT&T auch in den 30er Jahren
an Videotelefonie geforscht, übrigens
genauso wie Frankreich, aber wie in
Deutschland auch wurde diese Forschung wegen des
Zweiten Weltkriegs nicht fortgeführt.
Nach dem Krieg lag der Fokus vor allem
in der Entwicklung des Fernsehens als
Unterhaltungsmedium.
Da gab es dann Videotext
für Interaktivität.
Das kennen ja wahrscheinlich auch einige Leute
nicht mehr. Moment, dafür gibt es noch eine Webseite.
Moment, es gibt den
Videotext als Webseite.
Unwetterwarnung.
Videotext.
so viele Telefone langsam marktreif wurde. Link dazu ist in der Beschreibung. Und weil das jetzt
wirklich so viele Geräte und Entwicklungen sind, hier mal der Schnelldurchlauf der Highlights. Also
die Weiterentwicklung des Videotelefons hat wie gesagt Mitte der 50er Jahre wieder Fahrt
aufgenommen und dann gab es wieder einige Prototypen. Zum Beispiel hat AT&T 1956 hier
ein Gerät gezeigt, das Bilder... Ich könnte mir original vorstellen, was meine Oma zu diesem
Bild jetzt gesagt hätte. Wo ich irgendwie gerade dran denke, wahrscheinlich weil ich vorhin gesagt
habe, die eine hatte eine Frisur wie meine Oma. Wenn meine Oma das Bild gesehen hätte,
dann hätte sie gesagt... Ich kann es mir direkt mit ihren Worten vorstellen. Die hätte sich das
angeguckt und hätte gesagt, aha, das ist der Griff zum Wegschmeißen. Das war so ein typischer
Spruch von meiner Oma. Und das ist der Griff zum Fortschmeißen. Und das hätte einfach original
gepasst hier. ...über die normale Telefonleitung versenden konnte. Oder hier ein Jahr später auf
der Frankfurter Messe ein Prototyp, der über die damalige Fernsehtechnik funktionierte und
dadurch deutlich mehr Kabel und vier Bildschirme benötigte. Und im Prinzip haben sich bei den
Herstellern in den nächsten Jahren die Modelle durchgesetzt, die über Telefonleitung funktionieren.
AT&T hat es ab 1964 mit dem Picturephone auf dem Markt probiert. Die Geräte standen zu Beginn an
öffentlich zugänglichen Orten, waren aber relativ teuer. Telefon mit Wählscheibe. Tatsächlich hatte
meine Oma auch extrem lang Telefon mit Wählscheibe. Ein orangenes Telefon mit Wählscheibe hatte die.
Ja, sah sehr, sehr ähnlich zu dem aus. Orangenes Telefon mit Wählscheibe hatte meine Oma. Das war
wahrscheinlich auch das Modell. Das sieht dem sehr ähnlich. Das war ja damals Impulswahl. Ich glaube,
viele Omas hatten das. Das war ja damals Impulswahl. Daher kommt das ja. Du hast das hier ja aufgezogen
und das hat dann unterschiedlich viele Impulse abgesetzt beim Wieder-Zurück-Drehen. Du musst
das dann die Null... Ich erzähle das jetzt mal, weil wahrscheinlich die meisten Leute sowas nicht
mal mehr angefasst haben heute. Du hast das hier aufgezogen, dann hast du es losgelassen und beim
Loslassen hat es dann gemacht... Und diese Impulse entsprachen halt einer Nummer. Deswegen konntest
du ja auch... Deswegen durftest du den auch nicht schneller zurückdrehen, als es erlaubt hat. Also
du konntest da übelst dran drücken und dass es schneller zurückläuft. Aber dann hast du es kaputt
gemacht. Deswegen gab es damals auch Leute, die konnten mit dem Hebel wählen und nicht mit der
Scheibe. Versteht ihr, was ich meine? Also dieses Telefon wird ja hier oben auf so zwei Plastikdinger
aufgelegt. Und die Plastikdinger waren ja eigentlich dafür da, quasi das zu signalisieren, dass es
aufgelegt ist im Endeffekt. Aber du konntest auch den Hörer abheben und dann oben an diesen
Plastikdingern, wo du eigentlich den Hörer drauf legst, konntest du selbst Impulse wählen. Also
es gab Leute, die konnten mit dem Impuls... Die konnten Impulswahlen machen. Die konnten wählen
ohne Wählscheibe, indem sie nur oben den Hebel gedrückt haben, weil es hat ja auch Impulse
gegeben. Richtige Hackermans. War auch nicht wirklich schneller. Ohne Hörer. Leider haben
die... Hier steht überall der Hörer drauf. Leider nicht. Hier. Hier sieht man es. Guck. Hier oben
hast du Kontakte, wo der Hörer drauf gelegt wurde. Und auf die Kontakte konntest du selbst
Telefongabel. Ja, sowas ist es. Gabel. Ja, genau. Hier. Und auf diese Dinger konntest du von Hand
klicken und das hat dann gewählt, weil das auch Impulse gegeben hat. Also konntest anstatt
beispielsweise fünf zu wählen, konntest du auch auf der Gabel oben drauf hauen. Ja. Aber da muss
ich sagen, ich habe das noch mitbekommen, aber das war auch noch irgendwie so ein bisschen vor
meiner Technikzeit. Und das war damals auch schon komplett outdated, aber mein Oma und Opa hatten
sowas halt noch ständig in der Bedienung. Das führte dazu, dass sich die erste Generation der
Picture Phones einfach nicht durchsetzen konnte. 1969 gab es drei bezahlte Anrufe,
1970 kein einziges. In Frankreich kamen die Videotelefone wie hier das Visio Phone von
Matra sogar nie über die ersten Marktversuche und eine Konzeptphase hinaus. Die waren halt auch sehr
klobig und wahrscheinlich teuer as fuck und die Gegenstelle hatte dann keins und das scheiterte
auch an der Verbreitung höchstwahrscheinlich. Die Telefone kannst du nicht anschließen an
der Fritzbox. Die haben noch keinen RJ11 oder was das ist, Stecker. Kann man vielleicht umbauen oder
so. Die haben noch einen anderen Stecker gehabt. Die hat noch keinen RJ11, die Telefone. Und ich
bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob die Fritzbox überhaupt noch Impulswahl kann. Kann die
Fritzbox noch Impulswahl? Ja, die können das noch. Und eine Konzeptphase hinaus. Aus Japan
kamen beispielsweise Modelle von Toshiba oder Mitsubishi. Guck dir mal, die Japaner. Das sieht
gleich schon deutlich stylischer und praktischer aus, was die Japaner gebaut haben, oder? Im
Vergleich zu dieser klobischen Kiste von vorhin. Das sieht sogar recht stylisch aus. Sieht ein
bisschen aus wie zwei Rückspiegel, die man zusammengeklebt hat, gell? Linker Rückspiegel,
rechter Rückspiegel, zack, zusammen und dann Fernseher und eine Wählscheibe reingemacht.
Modelle von Toshiba oder Mitsubishi auf den Markt. Und Sony hat in den späten 80ern mit
dem PC-T15 ein eigentlich ziemlich futuristisches Gerät auf den Markt gebracht. Das konnte man sogar
einen Monitor anschließen und war so nicht auf den kleinen integrierten Bildschirm angewiesen.
Wie auch bei den AT&T-Geräten war die Bildqualität einfach zu schlecht und hat sich deshalb nie
durchgesetzt. Laut einer AT&T-Befragung hatten die Leute wohl auch einfach klein und hat sich
deshalb nie durchgesetzt. Laut einer AT&T-Befragung hatten die Leute wohl auch einfach keinen Bock,
dass sie zu Hause gesehen werden konnten. Und dann ist da natürlich auch noch das Henna-Ei-Problem
der Videotelefonie. Also die kritische Masse, die man erreichen muss, damit das überhaupt
sinnengibt. Habe ich ja eben auch schon gesagt. Das ist ja klar. Wenn du es kaufst,
dann hast du es nicht mehr. Wenn du es kaufst, dann hast du es nicht mehr. Wenn du es kaufst,
Das habe ich ja auch schon gesagt. Das ist ja klar. Wenn du es kaufst,
dann war das wahrscheinlich anteilmäßig extrem teuer. Und dann hatte die Gegenstelle keins.
Die Gegenstelle hatte sich keins gekauft, weil der Rest nichts hatte. Das ist immer
so ein bisschen problematisch. Es ergibt halt auch keinen Sinn,
wenn du der Einzige bist, der so ein System hat und wenn niemand in deinem Umfeld so ein Ding hat.
Warum solltest du dir dann eins holen? Einen weiteren Versuch gab es dann in den 80er Jahren
mit der studiobasierten Videotelefonie. Das waren Extra-Videokonferenzräume,
die man sich mieten konnte. Wir haben einen Preis gesehen, das waren zum Beispiel 2.300 US-Dollar die Stunde.
Ja, und einige Unternehmen wie IBM oder Boeing hatten sogar so eigene Räume dafür, mit dem Ziel, die Anzahl an Dienstreisen zu verringern.
Und auch in Deutschland gab es solche Studioräume, wie zum Beispiel hier in Hannover oder hier in Großbritannien.
Da haben sich Unternehmen wie Shell extra Studios bauen lassen, um sich mit anderen Niederlassungen zu verbinden.
Ja, aber auch das scheiterte, genauso wie der Versuch, in Europa an einem flächendeckenden Videotelefondienst zu arbeiten.
Im Zuge dessen gab es in Deutschland 1981 sogar schon fertige Pläne, innerhalb von 30 Jahren ganz Westdeutschland mit Glasfaser zu versorgen.
Ja, und dann gab es einen Wechsel im Kanzleramt und Helmut Kohl wollte lieber Kabelfernsehen.
In einem Paralleluniversum hat Deutschland heute das beste Glasfasernetz der Welt.
In den 90er Jahren hat man dann wieder an den endgültigen Siegeszug der Videotelefone geglaubt.
Und AT&T hat mit dem Videofone 2500 ein Gerät auf den Markt gebracht, das Farbbilder über die normale Telefonleitung übertragen konnte.
Möglich machte das ein...
Das, das aber auch... Leute!
Das Nazi-Telefon hatte 18 FPS!
Guckt euch mal das hier an!
...auf den Markt gebracht, das Farbbilder über die normale Telefonleitung übertragen konnte.
Möglich machte das ein...
Das sind 0,5 FPS!
Also, und da lagen jetzt was?
40 Jahre Ent... ne, ne, ne, 30 Jahre Entwicklungszeit dazwischen?
Krass, oder?
Also, so mies war das ja... nicht.
Was die damals zusammengebaut haben.
Chat!
Ne, ne, es war 1933, es waren 60 Jahre dazwischen!
Wie komm ich jetzt auf 30?
18 FPS?
Gut, damals hast du eine eigene Telefonkabine gebraucht.
Ein extra Chip zur Videokomprimierung.
Der hat allerdings die Qualität so bescheiden gemacht, dass auch dieses Produkt nicht den gewünschten Erfolg hatte.
Und auch in anderen Ländern, wie hier in Deutschland, gab es vergleichbare Geräte.
Hier zum Beispiel das T-View 100...
Es reicht für Mainstream-Verbreitung halt nicht, wenn du nur so die richtig Hardcore-Technik-affinen Leute begeisterst.
Ja, das kann am Anfang so ein bisschen für so Early-Adopter-Kram ganz gut sein, aber damit setzt es halt nicht durch.
Telekom.
Diese Geräte haben wie normale Telefone mit Bildschirm ausgesehen.
Im Prinzip wurde auf dem bestehenden Siemens-Telefon ein TFT-Display, eine Kamera und einen Prozessor angeflanscht.
Und mit diesem Produkt hat die Telekom eine große Werbekampagne gestartet,
die einen fast vergessen lassen konnte, dass die Videotelefonie damals in Deutschland schon über 60 Jahre alt war.
Damit schrumpfen Entfernungen noch einmal um ein ganzes Stück.
Alles mit ISDN.
Alles über ein Netz.
Crunch!
Und ihr habt es euch vielleicht schon gedacht, auch diese Produkte konnten sich kommerziell nicht durchsetzen.
Und das Video von 2500...
Bei der Telekom war wahrscheinlich aber auch das Problem, dass es wieder unsinnig teuer war.
...war dann auch das letzte Videotelefonie-Gerät von AT&T.
Nach 75 Jahren haben sich die Amerikaner dann damals final eingestanden,
dass die Leute vielleicht lieber nur telefonieren und sich dabei nicht sehen wollen.
Aber vielleicht lag es auch nur an der Technik, denn der richtige Durchbruch kam erst mit dem Internet und Voice-Over-IP.
Da gab es dann zwar auch Extra-Geräte für, wie hier von ARCore aus dem Jahr 2005.
Aber auch wenn diese IP-Bildtelefone direkt an den Router oder das Modem angeschlossen werden konnten,
war die durchschnittliche DSL-Geschwindigkeit in Deutschland damals einfach zu gering,
um flächendeckend gute Bildqualität zu gewährleisten.
Manch einer würde sagen, ist sie heute noch.
Da waren diese Geräte zwar vereinzelt im geschäftlichen Umfeld erfolgreich,
konnten sich aber auch nicht durchsetzen.
Was dann wirklich zum Durchbruch geführt hat, waren rein softwarebasierte Lösungen.
Denn als Skype 2005 eine Videotelefonfunktion hinzufügte,
war das auf einmal für alle kostenlos möglich, die einen Computer, eine Webcam und einen Internetanschluss hatten.
Und das wurden mit den Jahren irgendwann fast alle.
Und mit steigender Internetbandbreite stieg dann auch die Qualität der Anrufe.
Ja, und als Apple fünf Jahre später mit FaceTime und dem ersten iPhone mit Front-Facing-Kamera
die Videotelefonie auch noch im gleichen Stil mobil gemacht hat,
war das tatsächlich für alle nutzbar und das auch in guter Qualität.
Ihr guckt euch dieses Video auch sehr wahrscheinlich auf einem Videotelefonie-kompatiblen Gerät an.
Ja, und als 2020 dann das mit Corona losging, waren wir, glaube ich, alle ganz froh,
dass wir so Videotelefone haben.
Und auch wenig überraschend, dass das dann auch der finale Durchbruch
für die Videotelefonie als Massenkommunikationsmethode war.
Sowohl im beruflichen Kontext als auch privat sind die Zahlen da durch die Decke gegangen.
Ich erinnere mich noch daran, dass ich am Anfang der Corona-Zeit
auf so Partys auf Zoom übertragen worden bin.
Und da saß man dann so, haben alle so einzeln vor ihren Bildschirmen ihre Limonade getrunken.
Also es war interessant, aber das hat...
Das ist cringe, so nach dem Motto, wir sind jetzt zwar remote, tun aber so, als wären wir alle zusammen.
Da habe ich mich nach Möglichkeiten immer nicht daran beteiligt, an solchen Dingern.
...sich dann letztendlich nicht so durchgesetzt.
Aber im beruflichen Kontext auf jeden Fall.
Ja, und jetzt hat sich ja auch die gesundheitliche Lage einigermaßen normalisiert.
Und jetzt kann man nur spekulieren.
Gehen die Zahlen jetzt wieder runter? Bleibt das zumindest?
Ich würde sagen, circa 50 Prozent schaut gerade am Smartphone.
Beruflich ein wichtiges Kommunikationsmittel?
Und entwickelt sich das irgendwie mit...
Eine Remote-Weihnachtsfeier, ja, das kann ich mir wirklich cringy vorstellen.
Ja.
Schauen wir mal, was wird.
Was wird.
Ich meine, so ein kurzes Hoch an Videotelefonie im beruflichen Umfeld gab es ja auch schon mal nach dem 11. September,
weil Führungskräfte ungern fliegen wollen.
Es hat dann aber auch schnell wieder nachgelassen.
Wie ist das bei euch?
Benutzt ihr regelmäßig Videotelefonien?
Nervt euch das eher oder feiert ihr das?
Also ich sage euch ganz ehrlich, ich habe bei Teams meistens fordermäßig die Kamera aus.
Das einzige, der einzige Sache, wo ich standardmäßig die Kamera immer anmache, ist unser 15-Minuten-Daily-Geschwätze.
Ansonsten habe ich standardmäßig die Kamera aus.
Wozu brauche ich eine Kamera?
Wir wollen uns dann meistens irgendwas zusammen angucken.
Und die wollen mich nicht sehen.
Ich will die auch nicht sehen.
Und das passt.
Ja.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern, wann ihr das das erste Mal gemacht habt?
Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare und natürlich...
Das erste Mal Videokonferenz?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das wird aber schon ganz schön lange her gewesen sein.
Ich habe das sicherlich schon zu Skype und...
Nee.
Haha.
Das erzähle ich euch nicht.
Ich kann mich daran erinnern, weil ich das erste Mal Internet-Videokonferenz benutzt habe.
Ich sage nur, ich sage nur, kennt noch einer NetMeeting?
NetMeeting?
Das ist quasi so der Skype-Vorgänger.
NetMeeting, das dürfte das erste sein, wo ich Videokonferenz erlebt habe.
Gerne den Kanal abonnieren.
Konnte ICQ damals Video am Anfang nicht?
Nee.
Ja, tschüss.
ICQ konnte noch nicht mal telefonieren.
ICQ konnte Textnachrichten schreiben und Sumo-Volleyball als Minispiel spielen.
Sumo-Volleyball war ihr bestes Game.
Das ist ICQ.
Du meinst was?
Was meinst du?
ICQ hatte als Sound das hier.
Was ist das für eine pp-ige Abstimmung?
Achso.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, da fehlt doch noch was.
Was ist der Sinn von einer Abstimmung mit nur einem Felddrille?
PC, Laptop, Handy, Tablet?
Warum hat sich ICQ nicht durchgesetzt?
ICQ hat sich durchgesetzt.
ICQ war der mit Abstand weit verbreitetste Instant-Messenger zur damaligen Zeit.
Das hat sich halt nicht gehalten.
Aber es war bei vielen Technologien, die kommen und gehen.
Der Fall von ICQ ist immer unbedeutender geworden.
Irgendwann kam dann Skype und hat dem komplett den Rest gegeben.
Ich weiß meine ICQ-Nummer heute aber immer noch.
Aber ich logg mich da nicht mehr ein.
So, was können wir uns jetzt als nächstes mal zu Gemüte führen hier?
Was haben wir denn hier?
Die 10 besten Shooter aller Zeiten.
Okay, Leute.
Das muss jetzt sein.
Wenn Half-Life nicht vorne mit dabei ist, taugt die Liste nicht.
Also Half-Life 1 wohlgemerkt.
Es darf auch drin sein.
Ist auch okay.
Aber Half-Life 1 muss.
Also wenn du mich fragst, ist Half-Life 1 nicht nur der beste Shooter aller Zeiten,
gerade auch gemessen an der Zeit, weil er rausgekommen ist,
sondern auch eines der mit Einfluss reichsten Shooter aller Zeiten.
Technisch kannst du natürlich durchaus sagen,
dass Doom und Quake und die Itsoft-Spiele da mehr Einfluss hatten.
Weil darf ich nicht vergessen,
Half-Life 1 selbst basierte auf einem Quake-1-Engine-Fork.
Aber ich würde sagen, Half-Life war eines der einflussreichsten.
Und es ist für mich eines, wenn nicht der beste Shooter ever.
Okay, heute gibt es kein großes Vorgeplänkel,
denn ihr wisst, wieso ihr hier seid.
Ihr wollt unsere Top 10 der besten Shooter aller Zeiten sehen.
Und wir legen direkt los.
Aber zwei ganz wichtige Punkte muss ich noch loswerden.
Es geht auch super schnell, versprochen.
NordVPN kommt jetzt gleich oder sowas.
Diese Top 10 hier sind Teil einer viel größeren Top 100 der besten Shooter aller Zeiten.
Die komplette Liste gibt es auf GameStar.de.
Schaut dort mal vorbei.
Da findet ihr dann auch Half-Life 2, bevor jetzt gleich wer meckert.
Und zweitens, diese Liste hier ist natürlich objektiv richtig.
Wir haben das mit wissenschaftlichen Kriterien eruiert.
Weißt du, es gibt immer noch einen Riesenanteil an Leuten,
die verstehen das nicht, dass das ein Witz ist.
Die denken, der meint das ernst.
Also klar, im Internet tut man sich manchmal schwer damit,
wenn das eine gesagt wird und offensichtlich das andere gemeint ist.
Aber es gibt Leute, die haben da überhaupt kein Gespür für.
Die denken jetzt, wie?
Wie kann der sagen, dass das 100% richtig ist?
Wenn ihr also nicht mit jedem Platz einverstanden seid,
dann liegt ihr falsch.
Denn nichts an dieser Liste, absolut gar nichts,
hat mit unserem persönlichen Geschmack oder Subjektivität zu tun.
Videospiele sind ja wie Zahnpasta immer objektiv messbar.
Also, wer es meckert, wer.
So, und jetzt geht's los.
Let's go.
Dieses Video wird euch präsentiert von Genshin Impact.
Erkundet ab dem 16. August.
Meint ihr, der war auch schon mal in einer Wüste?
16. August.
Kraftes gibt jetzt Impact und stellen neue Genshin-Fan-Mei und Fremi
in der Trick-Off die Helden zum Release mit am 6. August,
um das Nummer 60-mal Primogems und 5-mal Adventures-Experience zu erhalten.
Platz Nummer 10, Quark.
Ja, dass ich das mit den Primogems sage, da waren sie auch ganz scharf drauf.
Quark 3, äh, sorry, Quake 3 Arena.
Quake 3 ist auch ...
Der hat die Top Ten auf jeden Fall verdient.
... 24 Jahre nach Release in Deutschland noch indiziert.
Deshalb läuft hier im Hintergrund ...
By the way, Leute.
Nur mal so für den Fall der Fälle.
Falls jetzt irgendjemand kommt und sagt ...
Sorry, Quake 3 Arena.
Quake 3 ist auch ...
Falls jetzt irgendjemand kommt und sagt,
guckt euch mal die Noobs an, die treffen sich gar nicht.
Das sind zwei der besten Quake-Spiele ever.
Es ist nicht so, dass sie irgendwelche Noob-Aufnahmen zeigen würden.
Ich glaub, Rafa spielt heute noch ...
Ja, das ist Quake Live, das ... Egal.
Ähm ...
Ich glaube, da spielt heute noch ...
Ich glaube, da hat letztens irgendein Quake-Turnier sogar wieder gewonnen.
... 24 Jahre nach Release in Deutschland noch indiziert.
Deshalb läuft hier im Hintergrund die Browser-Variante Quake Live,
die 2010 rauskam.
Und ich, ähm, okay, also ...
Lasst mich euch eine Geschichte erzählen,
die absolut gar nichts mit Quake 3 zu tun hat.
Meine Kollegin Petra Schmitz hatte damals über 2.000 Mark ausgegeben
für einen Multiplayer-Spieler.
Einen Rechner?
Nennen wir ihn natürlich nicht Quake 3.
Weil sie diesen besagten Shooter so ernst genommen hat,
dass sie ohne Internetflatrate damals ihr Telefon abrechnete.
Ja, so was Ähnliches hab ich auch geschafft.
Nur, dass ich MMO gespielt habe ohne Internetflatrate.
Da hatte ich auch mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 500 Euro.
Oder war das schon, glaub ich?
Ähm, 500 Euro oder so Telefonrechnung.
Online spielen musste.
So gut war dieses Spiel.
Verständlich.
Dieser Petra-Shooter nahm genau wie sie seinen Multiplayer richtig ernst.
So ernst, dass Profis sogar Effekte ausschalteten,
um die eigenen Frameraten hochzuschrauben.
Wahrscheinlich.
Oder vielleicht ist er auch schon in Rente.
Die ist ja auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Unter Arenaballereien prägte unsterbliche Begriffe wie Instagib
und zeigte der Welt da draußen, Multiplayer-Shooter sind die Zukunft.
Übrigens zeigte ...
Ja!
Und danach gab es nie wieder einen,
der so erfolgreich und bekannt war wie Quake 3.
Ich mein, es gab noch Unreal Tournament
und so dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen,
weil ich will Unreal Tournament spielen.
Aber Quake 3 dürfte wahrscheinlich trotzdem noch das Größte und Bekannteste sein.
... das 1999 auch ein anderer indizierter Multiplayer-Shooter
namens definitiv ...
Unreal?
Nicht Unreal Tournament.
Ja, Unreal Tournament.
Welchen auch immer ihr jetzt streng genommen besser oder schlechter findet,
diesen ersten Shootern verdanken wir all das, was danach kam.
Und was haben wir?
Viele Stunden in Multiplayer-Shootern,
wie definitiv nicht Quake 3 verbracht.
Hach.
Apropos verdanken.
Das Shooter-Genre verdankt Doom eine ganze Menge.
Das Deathmatch, grandioses Level-Design,
umfangreiche Singleplayer-Kampagnen,
unterschiedliche Schwierigkeitsgrade,
unvergessliche Monster-Designs.
Doom ist bis heute einfach Kult.
So sehr, dass es ja mittlerweile ein ganzes Sub-Genre gibt,
das Glanz und Glorie der 90er zurückbringen will.
Boomer-Shooter wie Warhammer 40k Boltgun machen ...
Der hat echt Spaß gemacht, das Game.
Boltgun hab ich zweimal durchgespielt.
Ähm, schwer war leider nicht schwer genug.
Find ich gut, fand ich gutes Game.
... aus ihren Vorgängern definitiv kein Geheimnis.
Und auch das erste Doom wird selbst 2023 von Fans noch gezockt.
Ja gut, es gibt ja auch 30 Milliarden Mods.
Ich glaub, Doom dürfte mit das meistgemordetste Spiel
aller Zeiten sein.
... Ballereien gegen höllische Horden,
das Abklappern von Secrets und generell der Charme dieses Shooters
einfach genauso unsterblich sind wie der Doom Marine selbst.
Platz Nummer acht, Max Payne 2.
Damit weg von den 90ern und hin zu einem meiner absoluten Lieblinge.
Ich persönlich mochte Max Payne 1 mehr.
Max Payne 2 ist heute eigentlich relevanter denn je.
Denn auf der einen Seite erleben wir nämlich
ein wunderbares Action-Revival durch Pistolen-Pornos
wie John Wick 4 oder Tyler Rake Extraction.
Auf der anderen Seite ...
Was für ein Ding? Wer extractet wen?
... im Gaming nach wie vor absoluter Mangel an Spielen,
die genau diese spezielle Stilrichtung von Action spielbar machen.
Die gute alte John-Wu-Kugelhölle.
Raue Anti-Helden und Heldinnen, die in Büro ...
Max, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
... Büroräume, Spelunken in abgeranzten Hotels
und Mafia-Clubs Blei regnen lassen,
die über Tische hechten, während links und rechts Kugeln
in PC-Bildschirme, Kartons und Ramschkisten einschlagen.
Papierstapel fliegen durch den Raum, der Putz rieselt von den Wänden.
Ach eben, John-Wu.
Und das natürlich noch garniert mit allerlei Bullet-Time-Stunts,
die fast völlig aus dem Gaming verschwunden sind.
Seit Max Payne 2 hat es kein Spiel geschafft,
das Meisterhafte dieser Schießereien würdig vorzusetzen.
Nicht mal Max Payne 3, so gut es auch sein mag.
Kein Stranglehold, kein Wett.
Und Gott bewahre, kein El Matador konnte es je wieder
mit dem Actionhoch eines Max Payne 2 aufnehmen.
Okay, lass ich mir gefallen.
Max Payne 2 war ein richtig gutes Game.
Aber ich fand Max Payne 1 ...
Hat mich, hat mich mehr, äh, abgeholt damals.
Jetzt irgendwer, öh, Nostalgiebrille johlt.
Max Payne 2 ist auch aus heutiger Sicht
noch ein verdammt guter Shooter,
weil in den Schießereien einfach viele ...
Ich finde, das ist ein Spiel, das kommt aus einer Zeit,
das ist jetzt noch nicht so wahnsinnig mies gealtert,
das kann man sich noch angucken.
Max Payne 1 sieht dagegen doch ziemlich altbacken aus.
Vor allem das Beste ist Face.
Das ist ja der Drehbuchschreiber von denen, oder was?
Der Story-Script-Schreiber von denen, von Remedy,
den sie da einfach als Gesichtstextur benutzt haben.
Ideen stecken.
Dass jeder Kill die Bullet-Time weiter verlangsamt zum Beispiel.
Oder dass Feinde physikalisch auf jede einzelne Kugel reagieren.
Max Payne 2 erzählt außerdem eine fantastische Geschichte.
Jede Figur kann Freund oder Feind sein.
Es bleibt bis zum Ende spannend.
Ich habe als Teenager Tage damit verbracht,
jede einzelne Action-Szene des Spiels rauf und runter zu spielen,
mit Mods noch mehr Manöver zu aktivieren,
den Matrix-Soundtrack reinzupatchen.
Ich konnte die Dialoge irgendwann mitsprechen.
Max Payne 2 ist bis heute ein absolutes Meisterwerk
und sollte viel mehr shootern als ...
Es geht Shooter, nicht Ego-Shooter.
Platz Nummer 7.
Rainbow Six Siege.
Heutzutage wird ...
Da kann man sich jetzt sicherlich drüber streiten.
Aber okay, es ist ja seine Liste.
Darf er auch reinbringen, was er will.
... gar nicht mehr so groß über Rainbow Six Siege gesprochen.
Das Ding läuft halt, es läuft erfolgreich.
Aber zumindest eine Sache hat Rainbow Six hingekriegt.
Die haben ein richtig gutes Comeback hingelegt
nach dem ziemlich verkackten Start.
... und die Fans lieben es.
Da vergisst man schnell, wie bedeutsam Siege eigentlich ist.
Der Multiplayer-Shooter startete Ende 2015
als eine kaputte Baustelle.
Die Matches liefen nicht richtig rund,
der Singleplayer war einfach nur lahm.
Gut, ist er bis heute noch.
Kaum wer wollte dem Spiel eine Zukunft ...
Das Spiel hat einen Singleplayer?
... garantieren.
Doch Ubisoft blieb an der Sache dran.
Und das zahlte sich aus.
Aber so sehr es uns manche Open Worlds auch weiß machen wollen,
ein meisterhaftes Spiel kannst du nicht einfach nach einer Formel entwickeln.
Schaut euch die ganzen Battle-Royale-Klonen an,
die auf dem Papier alles genauso wie Fortnite und Warzone machen,
aber es will einfach nicht Klick machen.
Na gut, das Ding ist halt so,
warum sollten die Leute irgendeine 0815-Fortnite-Klone spielen,
wenn sie auch Fortnite spielen können?
Und bei Fortnite merkst du halt auch,
man kann es von dem Game an sich, man kann es mögen oder nicht,
aber da merkst du, dass da Leute dahinter sitzen,
die wissen, wie man gescheite Spiele macht.
Warzone bekommt ja nicht mal sich selbst vernünftig fortgesetzt.
Rainbow Six Siege erreichte durch Updates einen Punkt,
an dem es für Millionen von Menschen Klick machte.
Die zerstörbaren Wände, die unterschiedlichen Operatoren
wie Sledge, IQ, Thermite und Co.,
die komplexen, aber lesbaren Maps ...
Battle Royale nicht als Armor-Mod gestartet?
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, dieses ganze Zombie-Zeug
und dementsprechend auch, sagen wir so,
Escape from Tarkov und so diese ganzen Vorgänge,
das waren Armor-DayZ und so was, das waren Armor-Mods.
Aber ja, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich kommt das auch daher, ja.
Six Siege bietet Teams unendliche Möglichkeiten,
die Gegner durch immer neue Strategien auf die Bretter zu schicken.
Dieser Shooter ist einfach magisch.
Und das alles in gnadenlos-tödlichen Matches,
wo eine einzige Salve den Untergang bringen kann.
Jeder Fan erinnert sich an sein allererstes Ace,
seinen allerersten Klatsch, an diese zig Momente,
wo es mit Ach und Krach noch irgendwie geklappt hat.
Ja, und an all die Male, wo man durch die Decke zefiert wurde.
Auch acht Jahre nach Release ist Rainbow Six Siege
nach wie vor ein Meisterwerk und der beste Beweis,
dass die Multiplayer-Welt auch heute noch richtig gute Ideen
und richtig gute Ausführungen zu belohnen weiß.
So, Platz 6.
I just came to say Halo 2.
Als Halo 2 im November 2004 erschien,
standen die Fans im Rahmen einer Launch-Party
zwei Häuserblocks weit Schlange auf dem New Yorker Times Square.
Szenen, die Gaming-Geschichte schrieb.
Bei solchen Sachen muss ich mich immer daran erinnern.
Hat das mit Halo nichts zu tun?
Kennt ihr das Video, wo beim Media Markt die Scheibe zusammenbricht,
weil die alle World of Warcraft kaufen wollen?
Keine Ahnung, ob es davor noch ein Video gibt.
Media Markt, Scheibe.
Mindener Tageblatt.
Hat Computerspiel-Fans.
Alles klar.
Vor zwölf Jahren.
Aber da bricht nicht die Scheibe.
Guckt euch das an, Alter.
Wie voll es da war.
Ey, weiß nicht.
Es gab damals ein Video,
da ist bei irgendeinem Media Markt die Scheibe durchgebrochen,
weil zu viele Leute drin waren,
weil sie sich World of Warcraft kaufen wollten.
Das war für die erste Xbox noch.
In einer Science-Fiction-Reihe,
die ursprünglich gar keine Fortsetzung bekommen sollte.
Doch dieser Hype ist ein Grand Poops
verglichen mit dem, was Halo 2 nach Release auslösen würde.
Im Single- wie im Multiplayer.
Ich spiele die Kampagne alle zwei, drei Jahre noch mal durch
und kann euch auch 2023 attestieren,
es gibt kaum eine Möglichkeit,
dass die Welt von Halo 2 auf den Markt kommt.
Es gibt nur ein paar Jahre,
bis die Welt von Halo 2 auf den Markt kommt.
Ich kann euch auch 2023 attestieren,
es gibt kaum eine bessere Shooter-Sandbox.
Gerade in der aufgehübschen Remaster-Variante
der Master Chief Collection.
Auf den ersten Blick bin ich bloß ein rüstiger Hühne
mit Pumpgun und dicker Faust,
also jetzt auch im Spiel meine ich,
der sich Raumstation für Raumstation
durch Alien-Horden ballert.
Doch unter der Oberfläche ist Halo 2
ein riesiges Getriebe aus kleinen Zahnrädern,
die meisterhaft ineinandergreifen.
Jedes Level von Halo 2 ist ein Erlebnis,
selbst beim wiederholten Durchspielen.
In einem Anlauf fahre ich im Panzer durch New Bombasa,
im nächsten wird mir das Ding unter dem Hintern weggeschossen
und ich muss plötzlich selbst überlegen,
wie ich die feindlichen Banshee-Jäger
ohne Riesenrohr vom Himmel hole.
Und der Multiplayer...
Och, der Multiplayer.
Halo 2 hat modernes Matchmaking auf den Konsolen erfunden.
Es war das Spiel, für das Freundeskreise
reihenweise Xbox-Konsolen zu irgendwem nach Hause gekarrt haben,
um eine mehrstöckige LAN-Party zu veranstalten.
So wie wir PC-Kids über Counter-Strike
und definitiv nicht Quake 3 schwärmen,
so jubeln Konsoleros über Halo.
Es gibt wenige Shooter, die so gut altern wie Halo 2.
Jahrelang hat die...
Leider haben sie es halt komplett verkackt, ne?
Ich mein, 3 war auch noch riesengroß damals,
mit MLG-Playlists und so was, aber danach ging's abwärts.
Konkurrenz versucht, das Erfolgsrezept zu kopieren.
Diverse vermeintliche Halo-Killer scheiterten kolossal
und bis heute verdankt die Halo-Marke
Wie ist Halo Infinite jetzt? Keine Ahnung, hat keine Spieler mehr.
War eigentlich ganz gut.
Zu Release.
Aber da kam halt nix nach.
Naja.
Naja!
Hat da weniger als Battlefield 2042.
Und was witzig ist, dass Battlefield 2042,
dass DICE das als Beispiel gebracht hat,
warum ihr Spiel so schlecht gestartet ist.
Destiny 2 läuft recht gut.
Und Bungie wissen ja auch, wie man solche Games macht.
Den Meisterwerken von einst.
Halo mag heute lange nicht mehr so wichtig sein wie damals,
aber ohne ein Halo 2
sähe die Shooter-Landschaft definitiv ganz, ganz anders aus.
Just one question.
What if you miss?
I won't.
Platz Nummer 5.
Hunt Showdown.
Als Hunt Showdown zum ersten Mal angekündigt wurde,
haben die Leute darüber gelacht.
Crytek stand damals nach mehreren eher mauen Projekten
in keinem guten Ruf.
Das stimmt.
Crytek hat ja auch mal einen MOBA gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht, was je aus dem geworden ist.
Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht mal released worden.
Dann kommen die mit einem Konzept,
das ja überhaupt nicht funktionieren konnte.
Wilder Westen, aber ich laufe nur durch Sümpfe.
Zombies ausgelutscht.
Und dann so ein merkwürdiger Mix aus PvP und Monsterbekämpfen.
Kein Fisch, kein Fleisch.
Wie konnte denn irgendwer das durchwinken?
Welcher Call-of-Duty-Fan verzichtet ...
Wie viele Spieler Battlefield 3 noch hat?
Schwer zu sagen.
Man sieht ja bloß die Steam-Zahlen.
Die Steam-Zahlen sind halt nicht gut.
300 Leute oder so.
Du wirst abends vielleicht noch 2 Server Rush vollbekommen.
Aber Steam, das Spiel kam auch erst 10 Jahre nach Release auf Steam.
Das ist nicht so wirklich repräsentativ.
Ähm ...
Battlelog ...
Gucken wir doch mal.
Du findest immer noch welche, ja.
Ja, guck mal.
Du kannst das definitiv noch spielen, wenn du willst.
Hast doch irgendwie so ...
Naja.
Sind wir mal kurz. Du hast 10 Server, die noch voll sind.
Wer, um irgendwelche altertümlichen Popelknarren
aus dem US-Bürgerkrieg zu bedienen?
Tja, eine ganze Menge.
Und genau deshalb ist Hunt in dieser Liste.
Weil es der gesamten Branche gezeigt hat,
wie wichtig es ist, kreative Ideen
und der Mumm und das Können sie meisterhaft umzusetzen,
auch heutzutage noch führen kann,
obwohl das Shooter-Genre sich mit Battle Royale und Co.
irgendwie festgefahren zu haben scheint.
Hunt Showdown ist in nahezu jeder Güteklasse ein Meisterwerk.
Ich meine, wie viele Multiplayer-Shooter
verdienen alleine wegen ihrer Soundtracks einen Award?
Wenn ich im Dickicht des Barrios von Lusiana herumschleiche,
entscheidet bei Leibe nicht nur mein Schussgeschick,
ob ich es hier lebend rausschaue.
Wait a minute, das war ein Hit?
Moment.
Was hittet er überhaupt?
Was zum ...
Fuck.
Ist das sein Spielerkopf oder was?
The fuck?
An der Hausecke?
Ja, aber der schießt nicht auf die Hausecke.
Der schießt irgendwo woanders hin.
Wenn hier einer steht, dann trifft er den aber auf jeden Fall nicht.
Ja, hier ist was.
Aber der schießt überhaupt nicht dahin.
Der schießt dahin.
Oder rennt der Gegner rein, weil Bullet-Travel-Physics und so.
... ein Schussgeschick, ob ich es hier lebend rausschaffe.
Hunt ist manchmal mehr Stealth-Game als Shooter.
Ich muss genau hinhören, was meine Gegner machen,
mich clever positionieren, Fallen stellen, antäuschen.
Und so entstehen Myriaden von Kombinationen,
die euch auf der einen Seite
schon in den ersten Stunden Jubelerfolge verschaffen,
und in den nächsten 20 Stunden hab ich immer noch das Gefühl,
bloß an der Oberfläche zu kratzen.
Hunt hat fantastisches Gunplay, das selbst Waffenexperten feiern.
Es hat nützliche Tools und Fertigkeiten,
eine faszinierende Southern-Gothic-Atmosphäre,
bizarre Horrormomente und Kreaturen.
Mäh, hab ich nie installiert, gespielt, sonst wie.
Das hat mich überhaupt nicht interessiert bis jetzt.
Und ein absolut meisterhaftes Sounddesign.
In keinem anderen Shooter kann dir schon ein knackender Ast
das Häufchen in die Hose treiben.
Jüngst erst wurde Regen ins Spiel gepatcht.
Und nur in Hunt ist so was ein großes Ding.
Weil der Regen auf jeder Oberfläche anders klingt.
Weil er die Matches komplett durchrütteln kann.
Mal zu meinen Gunsten, mal zu meinem Leid.
Und ich höre jetzt auf zu schwärmen.
Guckt einfach bei Fabian Siegismund vorbei,
wenn ihr verstehen wollt, warum dieses Spiel so unfassbar gut ist.
Ja, der geht da richtig drauf ab, schon seit Jahren, das hab ich mitgekriegt.
Guckt auf GameStar.de vorbei, da hat mein Kollege Jesko
erst vor ein paar Tagen eine Kolumne über Regen geschrieben.
Weil das in Hand ein Thema ist. So, machen wir weiter.
Platz Nummer 4, Counter-Strike.
Counter-Strike schlägt Wellen.
Hat es damals schon Anfang der 2000er.
Myriaden von Jugendlichen stürzten sich in ...
Wir hatten bis jetzt ein bisschen wenig Half-Life.
... nahelharte Multiplayer-Gefechte.
Es entstand eine halbe Subkultur aus Jokes, Soundbites und ...
Ich mein, ohne Half-Life wär's ja mit Counter-Strike auch nicht.
... vergesslichen Deamspeak-Mitschnitten.
Fast, dass zwei und andere Maps gingen in die Geschichte ein.
Counter-Strike war eine Startrampe für ernstzunehmenden E-Sport.
Das stimmt.
Es formierten sich erste Stars der Szene.
Kurzum, Counter-Strike ist einer der wichtigsten.
Aber oft bis ...
... Shooter aller Zeiten. Bis heute.
Aber Counter-Strike geriet auch selbst.
Nicht unbedingt meine Lieblings-Map.
... wenn jemand Videospielen mal wieder vorwerfen wollte,
die Jugend zu ruinieren.
Ja, das war damals ...
Counter-Strike war eine Zeit lang das Ding schlechthin,
wo viele so sich dran abreagiert haben,
dass es die Jugend verroht und alle das Amok laufen.
... sollte das Ding sogar indiziert werden.
Die Gamestar sammelte damals 25.000 Unterschriften dagegen.
Und zum Glück blieb der Bannhammer aus.
Gern geschehen.
Diese Kontroversen haben dem Erfolg des Spiels aber keineswegs geschadet.
Aus der einstigen Half-Life-Mod wurde ein Multiplayer-Phänomen,
das selbst heute noch die Steam-Spieler-Charts anführt.
Und das völlig zu Recht,
ist immer noch einer der besten Shooter überhaupt.
Und jetzt geht's langsam um die Wurst.
Platz Nummer drei, Battlefield 3.
Ah, ja.
Da, da geh ich mit.
... Feuerchen bekommt.
Die anderen Battlefields kommen auch in unserer großen Top-100-Liste vor.
Da geh ich mit.
Aber wir hatten beim Auswählen die Qual der Wahl,
welches Battlefield die perfekte Symbiose
aus unseren wissenschaftlichen Kriterien
wichtig und auch heute noch geil am besten abbildet.
Und wenn ich mir die Kommentare unter jedem neuen Battlefield anschaue,
dann steht da immer, ach, ich will einfach nur ein neues Battlefield 3.
Ja, das stimmt wohl.
Wobei ich seit Anfang an schon sage,
nein, ich will eigentlich kein Battlefield 3,
weil ich brauch kein Battlefield 3 Reskin.
Ich will ein gutes neues Battlefield,
was vielleicht das aufgreift, wo Battlefield 3 aufgehört hat.
Der Ruf der Sehnsucht kommt nicht von irgendwoher.
Battlefield 3 war damals in vielerlei Hinsicht
Formvollendung von all dem, was Battlefield so gut war.
Ich habe die blöde Vermutung, dass noch irgendein Call of Duty kommt.
Und das bleiben ja nur noch 2 und 1.
Und Half-Life muss, also wenn Half-Life nicht auf der Liste ist,
dann zweifle ich an der ganzen Liste.
... zerstörbare Umgebungen, riesige Maps,
eine beeindruckende Technik, ein geerdetes Modern-Military-Szenario.
Ich konnte Jets fliegen, Panzer fahren...
Aber wenn jetzt Battlefield 3 kommt, kommt bestimmt CoD 4.
Ja, selbst die Single-Player-Kampagne war gut.
Stellt euch das mal vor.
Ein Battlefield mit einer guten Kampagne. Sack Zement.
Da frag mal Alpha4Games,
wie gut er die Battlefield-3-Single-Player-Kampagne findet.
Battlefield 3 hatte unvergessliche Maps,
wie Operation Metro oder Caspian Border,
nach denen die Leute bis heute schreien.
Der Shooter spielt sich auch heute noch richtig gut.
Und ehrlicherweise sollte sich DICE
für alle Battlefields der Zukunft immer abschauen.
Das Problem ist, dass die Leute alle abgehauen sind
und sich irgendwie zu dumm anstellen.
Ich versteh's ja nicht.
Die bräuchten einfach Leute, die begeistert sind,
begeisterte Shooter-Spieler sind und sich mal angucken,
was Battlefield 3 gut gemacht hat.
Ich mein, ich weiß nicht, was sie die letzten Jahre übertreiben.
Keine Ahnung.
...so beliebt gemacht hat.
Dann passiert auch nichts so Murks wie bei Battlefield 2042.
Ja, na ja.
Platz so 2.
Siehste? War doch klar, dass so was jetzt noch kommt.
Ich will aber echt fernes halber sagen,
einflussmäßig war das auch ganz vorne mit dabei.
Da hat diese ganze No-Scope, Quick-Scope-Geschichte angefangen.
So richtig krass wurde es erst mit MW2.
Aber hier ging's los.
Wobei ich sagen muss, ich bin immer noch der Meinung,
heute, auch heute noch,
von der Kampagne her, vom Setting her und so,
ich fand CoD 4 am besten.
Ich mein, das hatte noch einen ...
Das war schon so Arcade-Shooter,
aber es hatte immer noch so ein bisschen so den ...
den Hauch der Ernsthaftigkeit, nenn ich's mal, drüber.
Der war ja dann spätestens bei MW2 komplett weg.
Black Ops 1 war nicht gedacht, irgendwie so was zu haben.
Black Ops 1 auch noch vielleicht ein bisschen.
Aber CoD 4 hatte noch so den Hauch der Ernsthaftigkeit, so.
Das war danach halt komplett weg.
Call of Duty 4 Modern Warfare.
All ghillied up, shock and awe, death from above.
Wenn ihr die Missionsnamen eines Shooters,
selbst 15 Jahre später,
noch auswendig runterbeten könnt,
dann ist das ein klares Indiz,
dass das Ding einiges richtig gemacht hat.
Und man muss sagen, in CoD 4, das war zwar schon ...
Die Amis sind ...
Wobei, waren ja gar nicht nur die Amis,
es waren ja auch die Engländer.
Superheroisch und so.
Aber es war noch nicht so dieses ...
Alter, Krieg ist das Geilste überhaupt.
Es war schon sehr ...
Ja, wir sind die Geilsten,
aber es hatte noch so den Hauch der Ernsthaftigkeit.
Irgendwie drüber.
Und das war danach weg.
Deswegen finde ich CoD 4 immer noch das Beste.
Auch was den Multiplayer angeht.
Das letzte große PC-Call of Duty war es ja letztendlich.
Ja.
Call of Duty 4 Modern Warfare
hat in der gesamten Shooterlandschaft
seine Spuren hinterlassen.
Und das sowohl im Single- wie auch im Multiplayer.
Ja, das stimmt.
HP-Regeneration.
Das stimmt. Beste.
Ich finde immer noch die Beste.
Modern Warfare wurden über die Jahre so ausgelutscht,
dass wir mittlerweile drüber lachen.
Aber 2007 hat es die Leute eiskalt erwischt,
dass eure Spielfigur einfach mal so den Löffel abgibt,
weil plötzlich eine Atombombe am Horizont aufschlägt.
Missionen wie der AC-130-Flug in Death From Above
sorgten für Diskussionen.
Modern Warfare war manchmal auch unangenehm, unbequem.
Und im nächsten Moment wieder ein rasanter Actionfilm,
wie wir ihn bis dato noch nie gespielt hatten.
Von unvergesslichen Zitaten wie
Was ist das überhaupt für ein Name?
oder die Tschernobyl-Mission
bis hin zum famosen Epilog-Level an Bord eines Flugzeugs.
Modern Warfare war im Singleplayer der Hammer.
Und im Multiplayer, da hat es mit seinem Progression-System
Das ist aber das Remaster, was man hier sieht.
Das ist nicht das Original-Cod 4, glaube ich.
Relativ sicher.
50.000 People used to live here.
Ja, ich habe letztens Tschernobyl geguckt, die Serie.
Und ohne Scheiß, das Erste, woran ich denken musste,
als bei der Kamera, das Erste, woran ich denken musste, ist
50.000 People used to live here and now it's a ghost town.
Mit Level-Belohnungen und schnellen Infanterie-Gefechten
in vielerlei Hinsicht den modernen Shooter-Multiplayer geformt.
Noch 10 Jahre später kupferten Multiplayer-Spieler
die Methoden von Modern Warfare 1 ab.
Und ja, die führten auch zu teils sehr aggressiven Monetarisierungen,
waren aber damals in erster Linie unheimlich motivierend,
weil selbst Neulinge immer wieder Hochgefühle erlebten
und Niederlagen sich nicht so blöd anfühlten.
Oh, ich glaube, ich habe in kaum einem Game so geraged
wie im Multiplayer hier, wenn irgendein Bullshit-Tode...
Also in CoD 4 weniger, aber in MW2 war ja Bullshit-Tode
an der Tagesordnung von Noob-Tubes.
Akimbo, Models, alles, ja.
Und nun zur großen Enthüllung großer Trommelwirbel.
Okay, wir hatten bis jetzt kein Half-Life.
Wenn da jetzt kein Half-Life dabei ist,
ich finde die Liste bis jetzt gehe ich soweit sogar mit.
Nicht bei allem würde ich sagen, das ist zu meinen Favoriten,
aber wenn jetzt kein Half-Life kommt, Alter.
Platz Nummer 1.
Pass auf, jetzt kommt Portal oder sowas, genau.
Ist natürlich Rambo, the Video Game.
Der gebatet uns. Der muss uns gebaten.
Falls euch dieses Video gefallen hat,
dann lasst ein Like und ein Abo da
und wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder.
Ich hab euch natürlich noch.
Gebatet, das war klar.
Platz 1 ist Half-Life 1.
Ja, Gott sei Dank, ey.
Okay, jetzt ist die Liste von mir auch offiziell abgesegnet.
Nein, nicht, dass es jetzt irgendwas ausmachen würde,
aber jetzt ist die Liste von mir.
Bestes Game, jawoll, sehe ich ganz genauso.
Das ist aber mit den Plushift-Waffenmodels,
die keiner mochte.
Ja, das ist mit den Plushift-Models, die keiner mochte.
Das sieht man auch an der Pistole,
das sind die Plushift-Models, die mochte niemand.
Ich kann, warte mal.
Ja.
Das wird der Zugfahrt.
Ich krieg heute, ich krieg den Text immer noch,
also ich krieg ihn nicht mal auswendig hin,
aber ich kann ihn immer noch mitsprechen, ja.
Ach nee, ich krieg's nicht mehr hin.
Aber, genau, dann kommt irgendwie.
Also ich krieg, ohne Scheiß,
ich krieg den Text heute immer noch halbwegs aus dem Kopf zusammen.
Warte mal.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das findet.
Ja, also ich kann's nicht auswendig,
aber ich kann's auf jeden Fall mitreden immer noch,
mitsprechen immer noch.
Ein highly trained professional, um genau zu sein.
Ja.
Ja, vielleicht sogar nicht mal Steam.
Half-Life war ...
Wahrscheinlich gäb es nicht mal Steam.
Gunman war kein Add-on.
Gunman war ein Stand-alone-Game von einem Mod-Entwickler,
das dann sogar von Valve selbst vertrieben wurde.
Und Gunman hat ein paar coole Sachen drin gehabt,
zum Beispiel steuerbare Fahrzeuge.
Half-Life 1 hatte ja keine steuerbaren Fahrzeuge.
Also du hattest Half-Life 1, hattest du die ...
Nein, nein, Gearbox war Opposing Force.
Opposing Force war von Gearbox.
Gunman ist ein Stand-alone-Ding gewesen von irgendeinem anderen Hersteller.
Opposing Force war Gearbox.
Leute, mit Half-Life-Knowledge kennt ihr mich nicht,
da kenn ich mich aus.
Das wollte ich jetzt nur sagen.
Genau, und Gunman hat ein paar coole neue Sachen reingebracht,
aber steuerbare Fahrzeuge hatte Half-Life nicht,
weil das war eine Limitierung aus der Quake-1-Engine,
dass ein Entity in der Engine nur ein Fahrzeug oder eine Waffe sein konnte.
Du konntest nicht eine Waffe und ein Fahrzeug sein,
deswegen konntest du keine steuerbaren Panzer in Half-Life machen.
Dafür haben die Gunman-Leute die Engine halb umgekrempelt für die Steuerung,
dass das möglich ist.
Steam kam mit Half-Life 2.
Ich glaube, Steam kam ein Ticken vor Half-Life 2,
aber Half-Life 2 war der Steam-Seller quasi.
Damals wurde sich drüber aufgeregt,
du brauchst Steam und du musst dich online registrieren,
so scheiße.
Heute ist es umgedreht.
Wenn heute ein Game nicht auf Steam rauskommt,
sagen die Leute, das kauf ich nicht, das ist nicht auf Steam.
2003 haben die Leute gesagt, fuck Steam,
warum soll ich ein Spiel mit Steam?
2023 sagen die Leute, ein Spiel ohne Steam, das kauf ich nicht.
Ein Fest für die Modding-Community.
Formte eine ganze Generation an Shooter-Fans,
bis zu dem Punkt, an dem ich mir kaum vorstellen kann,
wie die Gaming-Welt ohne Half-Life ausgesehen hätte.
Richtig, genau das denke ich mir auch.
So, und das waren sie, unsere wissenschaftlich korrekten Top 10.
Jetzt seid ihr dran.
Geigt uns eure Meinung, fordert eure Favoriten ein,
kritisiert unser Ranking, aber vergesst dabei nie,
ihr liegt falsch und wir haben objektiv recht.
Denn solche Rankings ...
Das hat er jetzt so oft so deutlich gesagt,
dass der Letzte gecheckt haben sollte.
Aber man muss das im Internet ja machen,
weil manche Leute checken es einfach nicht,
dass es nicht ernst gemeint ist.
Turok 2, das ist auf jeden Fall nicht in den Top 10.
Es stört ihn, dass man nicht über Kimme und Korn ziehen kann,
meine Güte.
Sondern Half-Life mit dem Revolver spielen, da geht das.
Aber na gut, okay.
Gamer von heute, ne?
Darf ich sagen, als ...
Nee, das war ein PC-Spiel auf dem N64,
war das einfach nur richtig mies.
Der erste Teil hat auf dem N64 keine zwei Meter Sichtweite gehabt.
Aber das war ...
Das hat komplett ...
Hier.
Das Spiel hat nur aus ...
Nur das zwei Meter Sichtweite auf dem N64, Alter.
Guckt euch das an.
Das bestand nur ...
Wahrscheinlich, weil es der N64 nicht hinbekommen hat.
Das bestand nur aus ...
Nur aus ...
Nur aus Nebel.
Und es hatte ...
Und es hatte Roboter anstatt Menschen,
weil Nintendo sich gedacht hat,
oh, Menschen in Shootern, das geht ja nicht.
Wobei das witzigerweise bei GoldenEye auch kein Problem war.
Das darfst du fragen, aber du bist nicht der Erste, der das gefragt hat.
Das haben schon ganz viele, ganz viele gefragt.
Und eigentlich sollten wir einen Bot haben,
der ...
das beantwortet.
Ja, genau.
Ja. Response Skill.
Okay, aber nachdem er Half-Life 1 auf der Liste hat,
dann darf er da auch meinetwegen Hunt Showdown und ...
Was hat er noch? Halo und Rainbow Six drin haben.
Wobei, Halo 2 lasse ich mir gefallen,
aber Rainbow Six und Hunt Showdown, ich weiß nicht.
Na gut, aber wie gesagt, subjektiv, wie er will.
Was hat man sonst noch Spannendes hier?
Irgendwie nix, ne?
Fireship hat ein Video, stimmt mir.
Stimmt, ich hatte hier sogar noch ein Fireship-Video auf.
Das haben wir gerade geguckt.
Ja.
Fireship hat noch ein Video.
Was ist denn das hier?
Die deutsche Bahn macht auf dick Hose.
Ah, das ist ...
Ist das nicht Simplicissimus 2 Channel?
Chinaschrott.
Was taugt ein 80 Euro 10 Gigabit Switch?
Ich gehe davon aus, dass die Basics damit durchaus funktionieren.
Advanced Features, Managed Features,
wird man darauf umsonst suchen, wenn man sie braucht.
Und wahrscheinlich ist die Geschwindigkeit in der Backplane
auch nicht allzu hoch.
Also wenn jetzt beispielsweise mehrere Geräte versuchen,
auszulassen an mehreren Ports,
dann wird es wahrscheinlich in die Knie gehen.
Aber ansonsten für den Heimbereich dürften 80 Euro China 10G ...
Switch ...
Was ist eigentlich ein 10G plus 2,5G?
Also sprich, der hat zwei 10G ab links und den Rest 2,5 oder wie?
Das skippe ich mal kurz drüber, weil das interessiert mich,
was es da gibt.
Herzlich willkommen, liebe Damen und Herren da draußen.
Heute widmen wir uns der großen Frage,
Chinaschrott oder kein ...
Der Femin ...
Feminswitch.
Chinaschrott ...
Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
Sag ich doch, zweimal 10G ab link und ...
Nee.
Sixport.
Also das sind 2,5 und das sind zweimal 10G ab link.
Ja, gut.
Feminswitch. Hatte jemand von euch jemals schon einen Feminswitch?
Ich wusste bis jetzt gar nicht, dass der Hersteller überhaupt existiert.
Switch, den wir manchmal in irgendwelchen Haushalten brauchen,
wenn wir dann ...
Alle schon mal gehört, es ist der große Netzwerkhersteller
unserer großen DCX, der Internetinfrastruktur in Deutschland.
Und die bieten uns jetzt auf Amazon diese Produkte an.
Und ich hab mir gedacht, ich ...
Feminnetwork habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ja.
Okay, China-Chinesen-Zeug, was niemand kennt.
Schauen wir das Ganze mal an, denn preislich ist es sehr attraktiv.
Bevor wir das Ganze jetzt hier verdrahten,
vielleicht wirklich, warum das Ganze sehr attraktiv ist,
da ist das Ganze auf dem Karton auch noch mal richtig abgebildet,
hier mit 6x2,5 und 2x10G SFP+.
Also wirklich interessant, für 2,5 sind tatsächlich nur die Kupferports.
2,5 mit Modulen oder, ja ...
Dann machst du eher gleich auch 10.
Das sollten sie auch eigentlich mal da draufschreiben,
tun sie leider nicht.
Und das Ganze halt eben hier für 89,99 plus,
da kann man gerade, wie ich das sehe,
noch einen 10% Kupongutschein anklickern.
Und ich kann euch sagen, wow, funktionieren tut erstmal alles.
Aber eine ganz wichtige Sache.
Ist der Synchronsprecher? Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Auch gleich einmal hier in ganz, ganz groß.
Es gibt hier vorne einen ganz interessanten ...
Nee, beides, das sind 6 Ports, guck.
Da 2, da 4, da 2.
Das sind Kupferports, das hier sind für Module.
Da kannst du dann unter anderem Glasfaserkabel anschließen,
kommt halt aufs Modul an.
Kannst auch Direct-Attach-Kabel dranschließen oder ...
Module auf 8,45, ja.
Halt je nachdem, was du für ein Modul hast.
Das sind schon 6 Ports, das stimmt schon.
Das sind halt auch die 10G SFP-Plus-Ports.
Ich zeige euch das Foto jetzt auch gleich einmal hier in ganz, ganz groß.
Es gibt hier vorne einen ganz interessanten Schieberegler.
Und da steht drauf einfach nur WLAN on off.
Fangen wir einfach an mit dem Konnektoren.
Hä? Ach, okay.
Wobei, äh, ergibt ...
Ergibt trotzdem wenig Sinn WLAN on off?
Ist das ein extra Management-Port?
Weil ich meine, wenn du ordentliche WLAN-Config damit machen kannst,
dann braucht es in irgendeiner Art und Weise Management-Möglichkeiten.
Was ist ein VLAN?
Man sollte übrigens zur Deutlichkeit wahrscheinlich besser VLAN aussprechen.
Damit kannst du, um es ganz kurz und ganz grob zu sagen,
damit kannst du aus einem physischen Switch 2 machen.
Ja, also, du könntest zum Beispiel einstellen.
Nehmen wir das mal hier.
Du könntest zum Beispiel sagen, okay,
Port 1 und 2 kommen in dieses WLAN
und Ports, keine Ahnung, in WLAN 5
und Ports 3 und 4 kommen in WLAN 6.
Und da wird jeglicher Traffic, der dort reinkommt, ungetaggt,
geht ja nur ungetaggt,
kriegt einen WLAN-Tag drauf und kann dann nur innerhalb von diesem WLAN kommunizieren.
Du machst dann quasi aus einem 4-Port-Switch zwei 2-Port-Switche,
wenn du das so willst.
Oder sinnlos machst du ja meistens bei größeren Infrastrukturen.
Und obwohl du hier auf beiden Seiten die gleichen, auf IP-Ebene dann,
die gleichen Netze vergeben könntest,
könnten die trotzdem nicht miteinander kommunizieren,
weil es eben zwei unterschiedliche getrennte WLANs sind.
Das ist quasi auf Layer 2 getrennt.
Oh, sieh, Layer 2, der Date, nee,
Data-Link-Layer, gell?
Please do not throw salami, pizza, okay, ja, Data-Link-Layer.
Das funktioniert folgendermaßen, du hast in einem Ethernet-Frame
hast du ein spezielles Feld.
Neben der Source- und Quell-MAC
hast du auch noch ein Feld für WLAN-Tags.
Genau, hier hast du einen WLAN-Tag drin.
Und hier bei Wikipedia steht es aber super, super korrekt.
Ich hab da aber auch schon schönere,
hier sieht man es schön, genau, ja.
Erkennung für Hardware, was das in Ethernet-Frame jetzt kommt.
Destination MAC-Adresse, Source MAC-Adresse, WLAN-Tag.
Typ Data, genau, ja.
Layer 3, nein, Layer 2.
Layer 3 hat das erstmal nichts zu tun.
Hast du ja auch gesehen, meine WLAN-Tag ist in einem Ethernet-Frame
und da sind wir uns ja einig, dass es Layer 2 ist.
Das kann man doch virtuelles Subnetting nennen, nein.
Das hat mit Subnets nichts zu tun,
da spielen auch keine IP-Adressen und sonst was eine Rolle.
Ja, also wenn du 2 WLANs hast und du machst irgendeinen,
du würdest irgendeine Layer-2-Kommunikation machen, ja.
Destination MAC-Adresse angeben, sonst was.
Dann würdest du den Broadcast schicken,
den würdest du auf der anderen Seite nicht sehen.
Das ist wirklich wie wenn du 2 getrennte Switches hättest.
Was wiederum geht ist, was wiederum geht ist,
Routen, das ist dann kein Problem.
Also du kannst ohne Probleme WLAN 5 nach WLAN 6 routen,
wobei du nicht wirklich dann WLAN routest,
sondern das ist dann halt eine Ebene oben drüber, ja.
Du hast dann irgendein Netz A, Netz B,
das geht zu einem Router, wird weitergeleitet zum anderen.
Dem ist das dann egal, was unten drunter für WLANs sind.
Aber im Prinzip kannst du da aus einem Switch 2 mitmachen.
Natürlich kannst du damit noch deutlich mehr anstellen,
natürlich kannst du damit noch deutlich mehr anstellen,
weil normalerweise benutzt du das ja nicht nur,
um irgendwelche Switche quasi zu trennen,
um die Geräte besser zu isolieren.
Also das ist zum Beispiel sinnvoll, wenn du WLAN-Access-Points hast.
Ja, du hast einen großen, stell euch mal vor,
ihr habt einen 24-Port-Switch
und ihr wollt da beispielsweise auch eure WLAN-Access-Points dran anschließen.
So, ihr wollt jetzt ja nicht unbedingt,
dass Geräte, die im WLAN sind,
physisch gesehen schon, wenn die Adressen stimmen,
irgendwie mit internen Geräten kommunizieren könnten.
Ja, und dann würdest du das in dein eigenes WLAN packen.
Das wäre dann wie, wenn du einen eigenen Switch hättest
für deine WLAN-Access-Points zum Beispiel.
Allerdings muss man sagen,
werden die WLAN-Tags auch an die Clients gesendet?
Nein, nein.
So pauschal nicht.
Das geht aber, das nennt sich dann aber anders.
Also es gibt zwei Varianten, wie du das machen kannst.
Das Klassische, wie man das kennt,
da haben die Geräte keine Ahnung davon.
Die sehen den WLAN-Tag auch nicht.
Das ist eine reine Sache, die intern im Switch gehandelt wird.
Der Traffic geht an den Port rein.
Dieser Port ist getagt mit einem WLAN-5.
Dann wird das getagt am Eingang des Switches.
Daran weiß dann auch der Switch,
im Weiteren, wie er das intern switchen muss,
zu welchem WLAN das Ganze gehört.
Und sobald es das Gerät wieder verlässt,
sorgt dann aber auch dafür,
dass es nicht aus einem Port rausgehen kann,
der in WLAN-6 ist,
wenn es am Eingang als WLAN-5 getagt wird.
Und wenn es den Switch verlässt, ist der WLAN-Tag wieder weg.
Dann gibt es die Variante,
dass du eben nicht das Transparent für Endgeräte machst,
sondern das wird hauptsächlich benutzt
für Kommunikation von Switch zu Switch,
dass du einen Trunk-Port machst oder einen Tag-Port.
Jeder Hersteller nennt das ein bisschen anders.
Bei Cisco heißt das Ganze Trunk.
Da läuft es so,
dass der WLAN-Tag zwischen den Geräten erhalten bleibt.
Dann kannst du dann einstellen,
z.B. auf diesem Port ist WLAN-15 und WLAN-25 erlaubt.
Das benutzt du oftmals
zur Kommunikation zwischen Netzwerkkomponenten,
weil du willst ja vielleicht,
dass du ein eigenes WLAN-5 für Telefone machst.
Allerdings hängt dein Telefon am Switch im 3. Stock
und deine Telefonanlage am Switch im Keller.
Da bringt es dir nichts,
wenn die unabhängig voneinander jeweils ein WLAN-5 haben.
Das muss getaggt weitergegeben werden
vom Switch im Keller zum Switch im Verteilerraum im 1. Stock
und dann irgendwie auch im 3. Stock oder so.
Das heißt, du hast einmal das für Endgeräte am Port.
Das bedeutet, sobald der Traffic reingeht, wird er getaggt
und sobald er rausgeht, wird der Tag wieder entfernt.
Das heißt, die Endgeräte merken davon nichts.
Und dann hast du das Ganze noch getaggt
oder wie das Cisco nennt, als Trunk.
Das benutzt du hauptsächlich zur Kommunikation
quasi zwischen Netzwerkeräten,
dass du eben so etwas machen kannst,
wie Telefonkarten in der Telefonanlage reden.
So, aber es war jetzt recht wirr und aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt,
aber so sieht es aus.
Wenn jemand sich das wirkliche Low-Level angucken möchte,
wie da was passiert,
dann kann ich euch nur den Cisco Packet Tracer empfehlen.
Das ist eine Software, sieht so aus,
da kannst du selbst Netzwerke zusammen klicken
und mit dem Unterschied, dass du auch das Netzwerk
in so einen rundenbasierten Modus schalten kannst
und quasi Package für Package simuliert durchklicken kannst
und reinschauen kannst, wie sind Header gesetzt,
wie ist Destination, wie ist Source,
was ist da wie getaggt.
Funktioniert das auch bei unterschiedlichen Switch-Herstellern?
Du meinst, wenn du Netzwerkgeräte verbinden willst,
die taggen, das ja, prinzipiell sollte das funktionieren
auch zwischen verschiedenen Herstellern.
Es funktioniert ja auch zwischen der Linux-Kiste
und einem Cisco-Switch zum Beispiel.
Das WLAN-Tag-Feld ist standardisiert,
aber Cisco hat natürlich wieder eigenen Shit.
Das funktioniert prinzipiell,
aber ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass irgendwelche Spezialdinger vielleicht nicht unterstützt werden.
Ich meine, es funktioniert zwischen einem Netzwerk-Endgerät
und einer Linux-Kiste.
Du kannst ja auch eine Linux-Kiste taggen lassen.
Du kannst zum Beispiel auf einer Linux-Kiste für deine Netzwerkkarte
die kannst du beispielsweise in fünf verschiedene VLANs hängen
mit jeweils unterschiedlichen MAC-Adressen.
Das funktioniert.
Und das alles über einen Anschluss.
Wenn es nicht tagged wäre,
bräuchtest du fünf verschiedene Anschlüsse
und fünf verschiedene Netzwerkkarten im Endeffekt.
Oder fünf verschiedene Ports müsstest du dran.
Und das ist auch etwas, was jeder Physi merken sollte.
Das fragen sie bei der IHK ganz gerne,
was VLAN für ein Standard ist.
Und das ist IEEE802.
Ich wusste, dass es Q ist,
aber nicht, dass es Q1 ist.
Ist Port Security nicht auch irgendwas mit Q?
Wie dem auch sei.
Genug.
Guck mal, ob der Switch was taugt.
Auch gleich einmal hier in ganz, ganz groß.
Es gibt hier vorne einen ganz interessanten Schieberegler.
Und da steht drauf einfach nur VLAN on off.
Lernt man in der Ausbildung BGP?
Ne, also weiß ich nicht, ob man das heute nicht lernt.
Ich vermute das nicht.
Wir haben das damals nicht gelernt.
Wir haben OSPF gelernt in der Ausbildung.
Also ich rede jetzt von der Berufsschule.
In der Ausbildung kommt es darauf an.
Wenn du bei einem Provider arbeitest,
dann kann das durchaus sein.
Ich habe damals ja meine Ausbildung bei einem Provider gemacht.
Also ich habe kein BGP direkt gelernt.
Ich durfte nie beispielsweise irgendwelche Sachen umruten BGP mäßig.
Aber wir haben OSPF gemacht intern damals bei uns im Netz.
Und ich habe OSPF in der Ausbildung gelernt.
OSPF gibt ja zwei Unterschiede.
OSPF wird ganz gerne intern benutzt.
Aber wenn es um Austausch zwischen verschiedenen Providern,
Carriern, was auch immer geht, dann ist es ja BGP weltweit.
Und ob man das heute lernt, weiß ich nicht.
Weil ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, was es ist.
Aha.
Virtual Extensible Laden.
Was auch immer.
OSPF is dead. Warum?
Was machen die coolen Leute heute?
Hochfahren oder gebootet ist die Kiste in drei Sekunden.
Weil Management gibt es sowieso nicht bei der Kiste.
Aber jetzt ist die große Frage,
wofür ist der Schalter, der hier vorne ist?
Ihr seht, das ist mein Eingangsnetz.
Kommt von meinem Switch.
Das schwarze Kabel geht hier ganz normal zu meinem PC.
Und wie wir hier sehen...
Was hat er eigentlich im Hintergrund da für ein Ding laufen?
Irgendein Grafana mit...
Request oder so.
Request von irgendeinem Webservice oder sowas.
Kommt von meinem Switch.
Das schwarze Kabel geht hier ganz normal zu meinem PC.
Und wie wir hier sehen, Ethernet 4, Netzwerk 22.
Ich hole euch das Fenster hier rüber.
Sehen wir, ich habe eine ganz normale Verbindung.
Ich habe auch eine ganz normale IP-Adresse.
Was er betreibt, ein dünner DNS-Dienst.
Doch jetzt kommt die ganz, ganz große Frage.
Wofür ist der Schieberegler?
Ja, dann erzähl, Sohn.
Ich dreh ihn jetzt einmal.
Ich bin auch gespannt.
Die LEDs sind gerade kurz ausgegangen.
Innen drin...
Die leuchtet irgendwie andauernd und immer.
Aber vorne jetzt vom Link her und so weiter
gehen die LEDs jetzt gleich erst wieder an.
Und wir sehen jetzt auch schon am PC...
Ah, er hat es jetzt gerade schon gemacht.
Er ist schon wieder hochgefahren.
Ich sage, Bootzeit ist einfach unfassbar von diesem Ding.
Aber es kommt jetzt nichts mehr.
Und nach vielen Tüfteln hin oder her
habe ich einfach festgestellt, alles klar,
dieses WLAN, und das steht auch irgendwo
in diesen Tiefen auf der Amazon-Seite,
ist eine Isolation zwischen diesen
4 2,5G-Ports.
Sprich, die haben dann
WLAN 5, 6, 7, 8
oder wie vergeben die dann?
Trotzdem.
Und deswegen liegt ja auch der 10G-SFP
anschließend.
Packt den hier rein,
steckt den einfach in einen der
SFP-Slots rein
und jetzt wird die Kiste natürlich quasi wieder einmal hochfahren.
Und dann werdet ihr jetzt sehen,
dass wir jetzt gleich ganz normal zwischen meinem PC
und dem SFP-Plus-Slot wieder einen Link kriegen
und ich auch eine IP-Adresse bekomme.
Wir schauen kurz rüber.
Netzwerk 22. Ich mache das Ganze
wieder auf. Wunderbar.
Ich ziehe das Fenster für euch ja wieder rum.
Das ist dann auch wieder so ein typisches, missverständlicher
Schalter an irgendeinem China-Ding.
Wunderbar. 4021.
Wir haben jetzt also wieder ganz normal ein Netzwerk-Interface
beziehungsweise eine IP-Adresse bekommen.
Das heißt, dieser komische
WLAN-Schalter hier drauf ist nichts anderes,
um halt eben diese 4 Ports
voneinander zu isolieren,
werden aber weiter ganz normal
auf die 2 SFP-Ports
drauf geswitcht. Das heißt,
und das ist auch, glaube ich, der größte Anwendungsfall,
wenn ihr da draußen mal auf der Suche seid
nach einem Medien-Konverter,
ich glaube, das ist mit einer der großen Anwendungsfälle.
Für den Preis ist das definitiv
sofort ein Anwendungsfall,
der mir auf jeden Fall einfällt.
Das Einzige, was wir bis hierhin nicht testen können,
weil auch ich hier nur 1 Gigabit hier habe,
1 Gigabit nur hier habe, ist halt eben irgendwo die
Performance. Deswegen werde ich jetzt das Schätze...
Ach guck mal, der hat auch so
ein gutes, günstiges
MikroTik
RJ45
auf SFP-Plus-Modul.
Da habe ich auch ein paar da.
Sehr praktisch, sowas zu haben.
Wobei, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein MikroTik-Modul ist.
Es gibt ja noch andere günstige.
Ich habe mir damals
so ein 10er-Pack gekauft,
MikroTik-Module.
Die sind nur
1 Gigabit, aber
kosten auch nicht viel, aber sind sehr praktisch,
wenn man beispielsweise Switcher hat, die
mehr
SFP-Plus-Ports haben als RJ45-Ports
und man braucht mal wieder einen RJ45-Port.
...einen 40G-Server
angeschlossen habe, werde das Ganze mal
verdrahten und dann schauen wir einfach mal, ob wir
einfach über diese Kiste hier mal ein
Iperf drüberjagen können, bevor wir dann
gleich ein Fazit ziehen.
So, kommen wir schnell zu meinem Versuchsaufbau.
Da steht die Kiste. Ich habe die ganz
normal mit einem DAC-Kabel hier auf
meinen MikroTik-Switch verbunden auf Port
22 und hier einfach mit dem
2,5G-Kabel geht es hier hoch.
DAC ist ein
Direct-Attach-Kabel.
Das ist
im Prinzip ein kurzes Kabel
mit Kupferleitung drin,
hat aber auf beiden Seiten schon SFP-Plus-
Modulstecker dran.
Ist auch das beste
und günstigste und einfachste,
wenn man beispielsweise
einen File-Server
lokal hat oder einen NAS
mit 10G und das möchte man
mit einem 10G-Switch anschließen.
Das Beste, was man machen kann, spart man sich
teure 10G-Module
und macht keinen Unterschied.
Und wahrscheinlich sogar ein bisschen
Strom sparen da noch.
Meine Teststation, wo halt eben, ich glaube,
sechs Platten drin sind, wo halt eben ein paar
Testdaten drauf liegen, die mit
2,5G natürlich sprechen kann.
Und das heißt, wir werden es gleich versuchen,
einen Stromverbrauch zu machen.
Ich bin immer wieder begeistert,
was für einen krassen Stromverbrauch die Leute daheim haben.
Ich meine,
ich gehe immer schon darauf hin,
dass mein Aufbau schon ein bisschen übertrieben ist.
Ich meine, jeder, der einen Rack bei sich daheim stehen hat,
der übertreibt es ja meistens schon.
Aber das ist nicht ohne hier.
Wobei das meiste, glaube ich, auch aus ist.
Storage und dann
ganz normal über den Switch.
Wenige Augenblicke später
melde ich mich zurück.
Ja, ich habe mir damals bei Amazon relativ
günstiger MikroTik
SFP Plus
aber nur ein
nicht SFP Plus.
Ja, genau.
Allerdings
29 Euro gab es
damals relativ günstig.
Die gab es damals für
ich glaube irgendwie 12 Euro oder so
das Stück.
Guck mal, was die haben.
Ja,
das sind 10G Module.
Die sind natürlich teuer.
FS.com, ich habe
FS.com Module
auch. Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher,
ob ich es bei denen auf der Seite bestelle.
Haben die hier einen gescheiten Filter?
Ich würde gerne Filter
auf 1 Gigabit setzen,
falls das möglich ist.
Nein, ich will bis 1 Gigabit
haben.
Filter nach
Oh Gott, ist die Seite kacke.
30 Euro.
Man dürfte bei Modulen nicht allzu viel.
Ja, okay.
Aber die Dinger sind echt teuer geworden.
25 Euro.
Ich glaube ich habe damals, ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Ich glaube ich habe damals 12 Euro
oder sowas bezahlt, Amazon.
Bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich die bei Amazon gekauft habe.
Vielleicht finde ich die da jetzt auch nicht.
MikroTik
Nee, habe ich nicht bei Amazon
gekauft, sieht man nicht.
Naja,
wie dem auch sei.
Aber er ist auf einer MikroTik-Kiste.
Zumindest auf dem Switch.
Schon mal sehr gute Wahl, dass er sich
einen MikroTik-Switch gekauft hat, als
Main-Unit.
War er nicht sonst immer Ultra-Unify-Fan
und hat alles mögliche von Ubiquiti
gehabt?
Die Dinger hier sind mega.
Preis-Leistungs-mäßig sind die meisten MikroTik-Sachen
wirklich gut.
...die ich für das TrueNAS brauche.
Ihr seht, ich habe gerade schon mal den ersten Test
gemacht, dass zumindest die Kommunikation steht.
Das funktioniert soweit und wir können auch
sehen, ich kann mich ganz normal auf mein System
dort einwählen. Ich habe auch das jetzt
extra mal auf, damit wir auch von dieser
Sicht einfach ein bisschen die Performance-Sicht
einfach haben. Wir fangen jetzt mit dem
aller-aller-einfachsten an. Das Ganze ist ja,
habe ich auch gerade gezeigt, an meinem Server verbunden.
Zumindest einfach mal als Backup-Destination.
Also ich gehe ganz davon aus,
2,5G ist für das Ding überhaupt kein
Problem. Fraglich wird das
aber nur bei so billig China-Geräten.
Wie ist das, wenn mehrere
Geräte 10 oder
2,5G machen?
Weil das zwischen zwei Endgeräten
einmal 2,5G laufen kann,
das sollte eigentlich kein Ding sein.
Aber was die Backplane wirklich
schafft, wenn da mal
beispielsweise an allen Ports es ordentlich
brummt, dann muss man
sich das schon anderweitig angucken.
Von der 101 hier starten
wir jetzt einfach mal ein Backup.
Das finde ich bei MikroTik übrigens auch ganz gut.
Die geben das immer an.
Wenn man beispielsweise bei MikroTik
keine Ahnung
sowas hier guckt,
dann kann man bei denen
Testresultaten, kann man sich angucken,
Switching-Performance mit Frame-Größen
und irgendwo
im Handbuch steht dann auch
ziemlich genau drin, was die für eine
Bandbreite auf der Backplane haben.
Finde ich
gut gemacht.
Da weißt du genau, auf was du dich einlässt.
Bei so China-Dingern eher nicht.
Aber gut, dafür sind sie billig.
Er hat alles durchprobiert und ist dann
bei MikroTik angekommen.
Dann
haben wir da eine ähnliche Entwicklung gemacht.
Ich hatte ja auch
einige Sachen durchprobiert, aber irgendwann
bin ich vor Jahren schon
bei MikroTik gelandet.
Was einfach eine super Kombination ist
aus Möglichkeiten,
die du hast. Kannst ja damit
alles machen, wenn auch nicht immer so ganz
klar in der Konfiguration.
Und Preis-Leistung.
MikroTik hat aber, finde ich, die letzten
zwei, drei Jahre ein bisschen nachgelassen
mit den Geräten.
Beispielsweise gibt es von MikroTik
immer noch keine gescheiten
2,5G
Switche, die sich so richtig lohnen
würden. Da müssen wir mal gucken.
Konnte man aber nicht
mehr filtern?
Als nur New und
Range?
Das ist ja Müll.
Wie gesagt, ich glaube, MikroTik hat immer noch
keine wirklich guten
attraktiven
2,5G
Switche und sowas.
Das ist ein bisschen blöd.
Wenn man 10G oder 40 sucht,
sind die wieder gut, aber
die haben ein bisschen nachgelassen
die letzten Jahre über.
Du kannst dann 10G-Switche auch
2,5 anschließen.
Aber es wäre halt richtig cool,
wenn die einen günstigen
24-Port-2,5G
und sowas hätten. Das wäre
mega nice. Haben sie aber nicht.
Er resumed schon die WM und wir gucken
jetzt einmal, das seht ihr schon, 250
Megabyte die Sekunde. In ganz klein sieht
man es hier. In ganz klein.
260.
Also das Maximum bei 2,5G
dürfte
oder sowas sein.
Weiß ich nicht. Irgendwie sowas.
Gigabit to
Megabyte.
Ey, Leute!
Leute!
Nicht schlecht, oder?
Nicht schlecht. Müsst ihr zugeben.
Fifet Quickmaps.
Oh, das sind 25 Gigabit.
Sekunde. 2,
Quickmaps. Also für Kopf
ganz im Ernst, nicht schlecht.
Ich meine, ich habe ein bisschen
gecheatet. Ich weiß, dass es 125
MB sind für ein Gigabit.
Habe ich das zusammengerechnet. Dann irgendwie nochmal 60,
bloß ein bisschen was drauf. Aber 312.
Aber für Kopf war das nicht verkehrt.
Ja, das wird mit Sicherheit ganz normal die 2,5G
sein. Wenn wir jetzt auf der Seite
hier schauen. Wir werden wahrscheinlich auch immer
wieder so einen Schwall sehen. Eher anstatt
halt eben eine durchgehende Verbindung.
Das ist von Proxmox vom Backup her
eigentlich ziemlich typisch, dass das Ganze
so abläuft. Das werden wir auch auf dem
Switch sehen. Momentan seht ihr ja, da
kommen hier nur ein paar Kilobits.
Ja, in einem Proxmox Backup weiß ich nicht, ob das so sinnvoll ist
als Switch-Test.
Entweder große Files auf SSDs kopieren
iPerf oder sonst was.
Oder Dings hier.
Wie heißt das?
Wie heißt diese iPerf
Alternative?
Die von BSD.
Auch ganz...
Nein.
Das meine ich alles nicht.
Das meine ich.
Naja gut, schauen wir mal.
Wenn wir jetzt einmal auf den
Switch schauen. Warum ich Windows 11 benutze?
Das ist ganz einfach zu erklären.
Ich habe gar keinen großartigen Bock
gehabt auf Windows 11. Genau.
Richtig.
Meine CPU, Windows 11 ist das erste
Windows, was meine CPU ordentlich
unterstützt. Das macht unterm Strich
nicht wirklich viel Performance
aus. Aber, mir
widerstrebt es, ein OS
zu verwenden, das meine CPU nicht richtig
unterstützt. Ach, Microsoft fehlt
viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Da haben wir es auch. Da unten
müsst ihr mal gucken, wo meine Maus ist. Da unten, wo
meine Maus sich dreht. Da seht ihr auch immer, es
kommt immer nur so schwallartig
an. Ja, okay.
Ist aber natürlich
minus Client. Ja, zeigt mal her.
Wie gesagt, der Test ist gut.
Wunderbar.
Man kann,
was ich gut fände, wenn man es
auf mehreren Ports gleichzeitig testen
würde, zum Beispiel
per 10G was
anschließen und dann von
mehreren Rechnern iPerf machen,
auf das 10G Interface. Da muss man nämlich
mal gucken, was wirklich über die Backplane
drüber geht. Das ist bei
den China-Chinesen Dingern wahrscheinlich nicht viel
mehr als 2,5G
mit den Ports. Wahrscheinlich kannst du noch nicht
mit dem Ding 10G machen zwischen den
2 10G Ports. Und jagen
einfach mal einen Single Stream los.
Also ganz normal, ohne Parallel,
ohne irgendwas großartig anzugeben
wie viel. Und ihr seht, wir landen
Also die Retries
bei TCP-Verbindung
machen mir jetzt schon ein bisschen Sorgen.
Bei UDP ist das relativ
normal, dass du
zwar keine Retries hast, aber
Datenverlust, wenn du nicht
genau die Buffergröße und Netzwerk
Bandbreite
einstellst,
scheinen mir ein wenig viele Retries zu sein.
Hier auf den
2,35 Gigabit.
Das ist auch das, das kann ich euch sagen,
ich habe das Ganze schon mal mit Gigabit getestet.
Da habe ich immer gelandet bei 112.
Ich meine, das ist nicht wild, muss man sagen.
2,5G
und ein paar Retries, überhaupt kein Ding.
Bei normalen Geschwindigkeiten
juckt null.
Ich habe das Ganze schon mal mit Gigabit getestet.
Und das liegt jetzt nicht daran,
muss man nämlich auch sagen, Leute sagen immer, oh, Packet, los, Packet.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das liegt höchstwahrscheinlich
da dran, weil einfach, das wird halt einfach
gedroppt, weil an irgendeiner Stelle
irgendwelche Buffer voll sind.
Oder irgendwie es nicht mehr angenommen werden kann.
Also das ist kein, oh,
Kabel kaputt, retry oder so.
Wenn er die
Geschwindigkeit ein bisschen runterschrauben würde, hätte er wahrscheinlich null Retries.
Oder ganz wenige Retries.
Darf man nicht von ausgehen, dass wenn man jetzt Gigabit
darüber überträgt, das Ding auf einmal
laufend irgendwas neu anfordern muss.
Gigabit, das ist auch das, das kann ich euch sagen.
Ich habe das Ganze schon mal mit Gigabit getestet.
Da habe ich immer gelandet bei 112.
Also man ist nie an die
vollen 125.
Wer macht das auch? Vielleicht sieht man mal
120, aber wie gesagt, ich habe auf der Kiste
immer ein bisschen weniger gesehen gehabt.
Es waren so 112, aber dafür durchgehend
und gerade. Und hier sehen wir gerade
das Vergleichbare. Das wir nicht ganz
die 250 sehen, aber ganz ehrlich,
280 Megabytes pro Sekunde
ist schon der Knaller. So, wir können jetzt einfach mal angehen.
Parallel 16.
Mal gucken, ob die Kiste auch damit zu Rande kommt.
Und auch ja, das kann ich sagen.
2,35 Gigabit laufen jetzt
hier wieder ganz normal durch.
Wie sieht es aus, wenn wir diesen ganz normalen Befehl
jetzt einfach mal auf UDP-Basis umbauen?
Und ich drücke jetzt hier einfach mal 10G.
UDP, gerade bei diesem Packet,
bei diesem Test, hast du immer ziemlich viel
Traffic,
der verloren geht.
Also Iperf ordentlich
UDP zu testen, finde ich,
ist tatsächlich gar nicht so easy.
Du hast ja
da keinen Mechanismus von
Retrys. Das kommt da einfach nicht an.
Wenn du ein bisschen mehr Bandbreite schickst
und auch wenn du es nicht genau tunst
an die
Buffergröße von deinem OS und
vielleicht dann auch noch die
Framegröße ein bisschen
hochschraubst, ist es schwierig
das
zu saturaten alles.
Bei Framegröße
hochschrauben geht ja gar nicht so ohne weiteres,
wenn es nicht beide Seiten unterstützen.
Naja.
Geh irgendwie mal reverse durch. Mal gucken, hoffentlich war der
Befehl der richtige.
Guck, guck,
31%, 12%,
32% Daten
verloren. Das ist
Iperf und UDP ist immer so ein
Ding, wo du als Netzwerktechniker
erstmal Anfälle kriegst, weil du denkst, dein Netzwerk ist kaputt.
Ach, 2,10.
Ist es aber gar nicht.
Es flappt jetzt rum, weil ich gerade auch gesagt habe, 10G.
Also die andere Seite versucht jetzt
gerade 10G dadurch zu pumpen
mittels UDP und das kommt
halt eben nicht an. Ich kann jetzt auch nochmal dieses
Reverse hier weglassen, dann sehen wir jetzt
hier auf der Seite wahrscheinlich, wie ich sagte,
deutlich mehr, aber wenn wir jetzt auf der
anderen Seite schauen, da kann halt auch
keiner, wie er pumpt hier unten jetzt gerade
4G raus, auf der anderen Seite kommt noch
2,3 rein. 2,38G rein.
Also auch UDP funktioniert in
diesem Fall hier wirklich ganz normal und
auch problemlos. Und damit will ich eigentlich
auch zum Fazit kommen. Du würdest gerne Linux benutzen, aber es
funktioniert nix. Dann
bleibt dir nur Arch Linux übrig.
Weil Arch Linux einfach das Beste
ist, was es gibt.
Da verstehst du zwar auch nix als
Einsteiger, aber du kannst immerhin sagen, dass
du Arch Linux benutzt.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist zwar wirklich ein Stück
Blech, was quasi nichts kann.
Es gibt vielleicht eine Isolierung von den
Ports, wer es braucht, okay. Aber
ganz ehrlich, aus meiner Sicht, für die Leute,
die dann doch wirklich, wirklich 2,5G
haben wollen. Also
mich hätte jetzt interessiert, wenn man das über mehrere Ports
macht, um zu wissen, was wirklich drüber geht.
Ja, aber ansonsten bestimmt ganz günstig
ja, gescheiter Switch.
Freitag geht meine Ausbildung los.
Als was denn?
Warst du mal auf der Gamescom dieses
Jahr nicht? Du meinst mal, ja. Ich war sogar
schon auf der, ich war mehrere
Male auf der Gamescom und ich war sogar auf der Games
Convention in Leipzig damals.
Aber ich war die letzten Jahre schon nicht
mehr auf der Gamescom.
Einfach, weil es sich irgendwie nicht lohnt
und anstrengend ist und
nervig ist.
Mittlerweile
wird man aber angeblich
von Security Leuten umgerannt, wenn man bei
ihm in die Nähe kommt.
Das war damals noch
nicht so.
Hast du das mit dem Flitzer mitbekommen auf der Opening Show?
Nein, habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Aber witzig, dass es jetzt sowas wohl nicht nur beim Fußball
gibt, sondern auch auf der Gamescom.
Das, was ich persönlich an der Gamescom immer
sehr nice fand, ist, dass es einfach so eine
komplett eigene Welt ist, mal für
ein paar Tage, wie lang man da ist.
Dass man mal Leute
sieht, die man sonst nur online
kennt. Das war für mich
auch immer so, obwohl ich es ja ansonsten mit so sozialen
Sachen nicht habe.
Das war für mich auch immer so
das Highlight an der Gamescom,
dass man schon mal ein paar Leute gesehen hat, die man
von YouTube kennt, mit denen man
vielleicht sogar online schon mal was aufgenommen hat,
aber nicht in echt oder selten in echt sieht.
Das fand ich immer cool.
Der Games-Aspekt auf der Gamescom.
Wir hatten damals ja auch tatsächlich,
außer nach dem ersten Mal Gamescom, wo man es ein bisschen
verpeilt hat, haben wir das auch
immer ordentlich vorbereitet. Ich bin ja da nie
allein hingefahren. Wir hatten ja
meistens, waren wir insgesamt
zwei, drei Leute.
Und...
Wir hatten auch noch Leute von YouTube dabei,
wo wir dann im Vorfeld Termine
gemacht haben mit den Herstellern und
uns verabredet haben. Dementsprechend
hatten wir auch immer ein ziemlich volles Programm,
aber es war trotzdem ätzend voll.
Der einzig ertragbare Tag
an der Gamescom für mich, der angenehm
war, war
Mittwoch war das, glaube ich, früher.
Ich glaube, das ist immer noch Mittwoch.
Wo es halt diesen einen Tag gab,
wo es noch nicht so voll war.
Ja.
Ansonsten konntest du dich ja kaum von A nach B
bewegen. Und ich stelle mir halt
gerade vor, Gamescom muss richtig anstrengend
sein, wenn du keine Termine im Vorfeld gemacht hast
und einfach zwei Stunden warten musst.
Ich kam mir, ich kam mir ja richtig assi
vor, ja. Wir waren damals bei
Nvidia, da war die, da war die...
Was war denn das?
Wird das noch eine Oculus, Oculus Rift
gewesen sein damals?
Nvidia hatte damals einen VR-Stand,
wo es diese Portal-Demo
gab.
Habt bestimmt einige von euch gesehen.
Die Portal-VR-Demo, die war richtig
gut. Und
da haben wir so eine Eintrittskarte bekommen.
Wir waren bei Nvidia und die haben gesagt, hey, habt ihr schon,
wart ihr schon an unserem VR-Stand?
So, nee, wussten wir gar nicht, dass ihr einen habt. Ja, hier,
komm, kriegt ihr eine Eintrittskarte.
Geht da einfach hin, zeigt die, dann könnt ihr
euch das angucken. Da sind wir da halt hin
und das war zum damaligen Zeitpunkt um den
Nvidia-Stand. War, also
normalerweise hast du ja immer so einen Gamescom-Stand
und da steht dann,
was weiß ich,
Schlange bis hierhin und
beim Nvidia-Stand für die VR-Brille
war die Schlange dreimal um
den Stand gewickelt. Die war dreimal länger
als es sein dürfte,
als es sein sollte.
Und das kam mir schon damals richtig assi vor.
Da sind wir an dem Stand vorbeigegangen und haben gesagt,
oh cool, würde ich mir gerne mal angucken.
Wir haben ja hier die Karte gekriegt, sollen
wir einfach am Stand vorbeigehen. Bin ich mit der Karte
halt zum Nvidia-Stand und die haben gesagt, ja,
kommt mit rein. Und da haben die uns halt
vorbeigeführt an irgendwie Leuten, die
dann am drei Stunden oder am zweieinhalb
Stunden Wartemarker standen.
Habe ich mir schon irgendwie
ein bisschen doof vor, ja.
Deswegen war ich immer
ganz froh, wenn diese ganzen Termine
nicht an den gleichen
öffentlichen Ständen waren oder diesen
kleinen Abteil hatten,
bei Blizzard war das so, für Hearthstone damals,
da hat es so eine Ecke, da wurde es
dann an der Seite reingeschleust.
Das kam mir
immer echt blöd vor, wenn du da
vorbeigeführt wurdest und irgendwie Leute stehen da
zweieinhalb Stunden an und
bist dann auch doof angeguckt von allen.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Dafür kriegst, dafür,
damit nicht. Du musst im Vorfeld
dich wirklich drum kümmern und Termine machen.
Du kannst nicht einfach mit einem Ausweis
da hingehen und sagen, hallo, ich bin der Max,
ich will da gerne rein. Ne, ne.
Also reine
Presseakkreditierung oder sowas für die
Gamescom bringt dir nix. Du musst im Vorfeld
wirklich Termine mit den Herstellern machen.
Sonst wird das nix. Gut, wenn
die auf so einem Termin dann die
die Hersteller
irgendeinen Ausweis in die Hand drücken oder
irgendeinen Eintrittsding
für ihren Stand, wo die das geregelt
haben. Es gibt ja Leute, die
haben solche Pässe dann kopiert,
hab ich gehört.
Erinnert sich noch jemand?
Fastpass-Kopieraktion.
Da gab's richtig, da ging's
richtig zur Sache.
Nuku, dankeschön.
Ah, du hast dich umbenannt, gell?
Ich erkenne es, du hast dich wieder umbenannt.
Danke
für den Sub.
Genau, ja.
Was da gelaufen
ist im Hintergrund, man.
Ich weiß ja heute immer noch nicht,
wem ich die Story da glauben soll.
Ja, also egal, ist so lange her.
Groove Electric,
Pog-Subscription. Leute, bald ist es soweit.
Bald ist wieder der Erste, dann werden alle
Subs frei.
Twitch-Usernamen mit bedacht wählen.
Oh, Besos muss
ins Weltall, Leute.
Noch was anderes.
Wenn euch mein Content auf Twitch gefällt,
ich will gar nicht Prime-Subscribed
werden. Natürlich auch, hab ich keine Schmerzen mit,
ja? Aber wenn's euch gefällt, könnt ihr mir auch
gerne followen. Ist auch schon sehr nice.
Macht der,
ich hab keine Ahnung, keinen Schimmer mehr,
ob der überhaupt noch was macht.
Ne.
Ich bin zwischendrin so im Poker-Game am Start.
Dubai, man, alter.
Was machen die da alle?
Muss man da wenig Steuern
bezahlen? Leute, ich muss
heute echt ein Video aufnehmen.
Wird mir echt wieder Zeit.
Rambo ist wieder aktiv.
Meine Güte.
Ne, das mach ich nicht auf
YouTube.
Ja, hab ich schon. Ja, ja, hab ich schon.
Das wird übelster,
übelster Gbay-Titel. Wobei,
mit nem Funken Wahrheit dabei, natürlich.
Leute, ich geh jetzt
was essen. Ich hab Hunger.
WilderEgel, 50
Milliarden. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Was denn? Schaltet mir
in die Animationen auf Twitch frei. Oder kann man die,
ich hab noch nie Bits gegiftet.
Kann man die beim Bitsgiften
auswählen? Ich würd sagen,
nehm gar keine Kubernetes-Installer-
Geschichten.
Find ich total unsinnig.
Ja, trinken hab ich
grad schon. Aber schön, dass du mich erinnerst.
Heute waren wir nicht sonderlich
produktiv. Ich glaub, wir haben's geschafft.
Leute, ich glaub, haben wir's
geschafft, in 3 Stunden 3 Videos zu gucken?
Oder so?
Heute gibt's kein Nudeln mit Lachs.
Heute gibt's Nudeln mit Tomatensauce
und Hackfleisch.
Ja, Kubernetes updaten ist gar nicht so einfach.
Also zumindest, wenn es bei Cloud-Anbietern
ist. Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es bei Selbstinstalliertem
auch so ist. Aber ich glaube, dass es
auch so ist. Da hatte ich noch nie so ein
Outdated-Kubernetes. Du kannst ja nicht
von einer alten Version auf eine neue Version
updaten. Du musst von einer alten Version auf eine alte
Version, auf eine alte Version, auf eine alte Version,
auf eine nicht mehr ganz so alte Version
und dann irgendwann mal auf eine neue supportete
Version. Ist aber auch verständlich.
Die haben so viele neue Sachen an
Resource-Types und so, was sie
supporten und was dann irgendwie umgestellt
wird. Das kann ich verstehen.
Bei Google ist es relativ easy.
Wenn du einen Managed-Google-Kubernetes-Cluster hast,
der wird zwangsgeupdatet.
Du hast gar keine Chance, da rauszukommen.
Du kannst die Updates
deaktivieren, einmalig für 30 Tage.
Aber
danach kriegst du zwanghaft
ein Update aufgedrückt, ob du willst oder nicht.
Finde ich aber auch gut.
Dann machen sich erstens die Leute Gedanken
darauf, wie sie ihre Anwendungen
darauf laufen lassen.
Sodass die Anwendung
halt auch mal einen Restart überlebt.
Weil eine Anwendung, die in Kubernetes läuft,
die keinen Restart überlebt, ist halt
für den Arsch.
Und du hast nicht das Problem,
dass du irgendwann komplett outdated bist.
Oder die Leute gehen zu AKS.
Da kriegen sie aber meiner Ansicht nach den schlechteren
Kubernetes-Managed-Kubernetes.
Wobei AKS auch in Ordnung ist.
Ich kannte AKS vor
Google-Kubernetes.
Weil wir bei der alten Firma hauptsächlich Azure hatten.
Aber ich muss sagen,
insgesamt gefällt mir
das Paket besser von Google.
Also mir gefällt GKE besser.
Am schlechtesten ist ja wohl EKS.
Vom Hörensagen habe ich die Steps.
AWS.
EKS
ist der Kubernetes-Server von AWS.
Bei Elastic
Kubernetes, glaube ich.
Vom Hörensagen her soll der der Schlechteste sein.
Von allen drei.
Das ist sicherlich sehr abartig.
Ich mache ja auch hauptsächlich
aktuell Kubernetes, und zwar im Google-Umfeld.
Und so langsam, aber sicher, muss ich
ehrlich sagen. Ich kannte mich schon, bevor
ich dort angefangen habe, ganz brauchbar damit aus.
Aber gerade so Feinheiten
kriegt man erst raus,
wenn man das wirklich täglich benutzt.
Zum Beispiel habe ich letztens rausgefunden,
es gibt einen Servicetyp
in Kubernetes, der einen DNS-Alias
setzen kann. Was mega
praktisch ist, wenn du
für alle Cluster-Ressourcen
den gleichen Namen
verwenden möchtest.
Wenn du für alle Cluster-Ressourcen den gleichen Namen
verwenden möchtest, in unterschiedlichen Umgebungen.
Stell dir mal vor, man hat ein Testing,
ein Testing und ein
Live-Environment und möchte
im Cluster selbst die gleichen Namen
verwenden für externe Dienste.
Dann kannst du beispielsweise einen Service setzen,
der einen DNS-Alias im Cluster
anlegt. Das ist schon wirklich...
Da kommt man aber erst drauf, wenn man es eine Weile verwendet hat.
Da würde ich dem Airfox
Recht geben, je nachdem, was du geschrieben hast.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Was hat er denn geschrieben?
Ach hier, man braucht es, wenn man nichts
zu automatisieren hat.
Dem hier würde ich
Recht geben. Allerdings
bietet sich Kubernetes oftmals auch an,
einiges automatischer
zu machen, weil die Anwendungen eben
darauf ausgelegt sind, dass sie ohne Probleme
dort gestoppt werden können,
dort gestartet werden können.
Was ja viele klassische Anwendungen nicht so gut
verkraften.
Oftmals die ein bisschen Jahre auf dem Buckel
haben.
Das sind vielleicht Jahrveranwendungen, die erst mal 8 Minuten brauchen,
bis sie gestartet sind und sowas.
Wann kommt eigentlich Season
BF2? Ich weiß nicht, Season 6?
Im Oktober?
Okay, Leute, ich gehe jetzt futtern.
Mal gucken, wann wir uns
sehen. Ich hoffe, also
morgen auf jeden Fall, morgen bin ich auf jeden Fall am Start.
Ob ich heute Abend nochmal am Start bin, weiß
ich nicht. Wir könnten nochmal
3 Stunden Baldur's Gate
spielen.
Akt 1 ist durch.
Nach, frag mich nicht, 50 Stunden
oder so. Wobei ich noch
ein paar Sachen offen habe.
Mal gucken. Morgen bin ich auf jeden Fall
am Start und eventuell sollte
ich mich jetzt einfach mal nach dem Mittagessen hinsetzen
und YouTube aufnehmen. Ich glaube, das mache
ich. Leute,
wir sehen uns. Bis denn, macht's gut.
See you.